good morning everyone
in the interest of keeping the clocks
and keeping the trains rather running on
time i'd like to call to order the
meeting of the science technology and
energy committee and a happy february
1st to all
our meetings which typically this year
so far have been on tuesdays
but to
upset that apple cart a little bit i
will remind everyone that next monday
we will meet again in this room we will
have a public hearing
a continuation of a public hearing on
house bill 1644
at 1 pm
and then at 2 pm we will convene an
executive session
on the 5 bills
that have been designated as early bills
by the clerk of the house
those bills have to be
reported on by february 17th
but
due to
some scheduling issues we've been
informed that they actually must be done
by february 10th
so we will
report
we'll have an exact session and report
on those bills next monday february 7th
we will meet again the next day tuesday
february 8th
to hear the final six bills
that
six house bills anyway that will come
before us this year
it has not yet
been determined exactly when we will
exec the rest of our bills but we're
looking right now at the week of
february
21st
so tuesday february 22nd would be a
likely candidate
and another likely candidate would be
the following tuesday which would be
march 1st
so representative callie pitts you have
a question i have a question about
we're going to exec and normally
executive sessions
is when we do business when we talk
and i i just wondered if we were going
to do any
discussion of any of these bills because
we're going quite late in the day
that's all and then it just seemed like
the public hearing we're
more or less discussing at the public
hearing but that's not normally the way
okay well thank you for that question
we
typically do confine our
intra
committee discussions to either
subcommittee work sessions
full committee work sessions or
because we've had very few people
testifying on a couple of recent bills
last week for example we did have some
intra
committee discussion
of a couple of those bills simply
because we had the time to do that and i
will continue to do that going forward
if we have the time we will have those
we're basically
full committee
work session at that point
um so it's a it's an appropriate thing
now because we're having an exec session
next monday february 7th i would alert
all committee members
that if you know you cannot be here next
monday february 7th
either contact myself
or representative samsich
to arrange for a
a substitute for yourself if you can't
be here so as soon as you know that you
can't be here
let one of us know so that we can make
have house leadership
assign some
substitutes
so that we'll be able to have a full
complement of members to
before we get started this morning i
want to
issue an apology to all members of the
committee for a mistake that i have made
over the course of the last few weeks
and that mistake is i have neglected to
ask
a member to retrieve the blue sheets
in the back of the room
and report
at the end of each public hearing how
many people signed up for and or against
the bill
and so i apologize for that oversight
and i will correct it today by making
sure that
uh
representative pimentel
retrieves those blue sheets and lets us
know who was in favor and who was
opposed to a bill
also before we start this morning i'll
remind everyone that if you intend to
testify on a bill
we need
a pink card
otherwise we won't know that you intend
to testify
and therefore we
won't call on you so please submit
a pink card it's
essential for record record keeping
after the public hearing as well as for
processing of the public hearing so that
we'll know who wants to speak and how
much time to give each of those persons
to speak
i'd also remind
people in the audience
that if you do intend to speak
you should maximize the time that you
have to speak
by not spending a lot of time
telling us about your background what
your credentials are
the best place to do that would be in an
email to the committee rather than
taking up valuable testimony time by
doing it here in front of us all so
in the future
both today and
going forward
i'd urge you all to
refrain from going into lengthy
descriptions of your background
well we all appreciate your background
it may not be the most appropriate way
to
bring that to our attention
are there any issues that committee
members have that they would like to
discuss before we get started this
morning mr chair
representative thomas yes thank you uh
just to add on uh in in in addition to
february 7th
there will also be a
uh continuation of the
subcommittee for hb 1644 at 12 30 it'll
be a brief
final subcommittee meeting before the
two o'clock exec session
okay thank you
anybody else on the committee have
anything to uh
okay seeing none
i will open the public hearing on
which is about limiting air emissions of
perfluorochemicals and i will ask the
prime sponsor of hb 1546
representative
go ahead representative cambril i think
we forgot to do the pledge
did that again thank you for bringing
that to my attention so before we call
on representative boyd please join us as
representative cam brills leads us in
the pledge
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
sorry about that okay now we can call on
representative boyd to introduce house
bill
[Music]
mr chairman thank you very much for
having me today and through you
to my esteemed colleagues of the new
hampshire general court
my name is bill boyd
from hillsboro district 21 representing
the town of merrimack
and i'm before you
as the prime sponsor of house bill 1546
which is an act limiting your emissions
of
perfluorochemicals
the genesis behind
my bill
for
limiting
pounds of pfas emitted annually at 45
was based on
a couple different reports that i had
read the state of michigan
state of new york and state of minnesota
had done studies regarding
pfas
infiltrating the year and actually
quantifying
um
the amount of
chemicals that per pounds are being
my word belched into the into the
atmosphere that's how i arrived at
45 pounds in in contrast the state of
texas actually did a study
and there they have a i don't think it's
a regulation but they were looking at a
advisory of 5 000 pounds
annually of pfas that was being admitted
specifically the the legislation targets
short change p5 substances long chain
precursor compounds in any new genex
chemical that is being created
that's what the lsr was and that is the
bill that is before you
once the bill was drafted i received an
email from kathy beam
asking if i could sit down with des and
talk about my bill and to be very candid
with you folks i'm very grateful
to mike fitzgerald gary milbury craig
wright and kathy beam for
talking to me about 1546 and explaining
to me how
it was not manageable from from a des
perspective
we had a
very cordial very frank dialogue
regarding about air quality standards as
it relates to pfas in new hampshire
and kind of indicated to me that this
was something that they could not in
good faith um support
so i asked them i said well is there
something that i could offer
that would begin
to tackle
air quality as it relates to pfas in the
state of new hampshire
um
again i'm kathy beam is here today i'm
very grateful to her and
um
i spoke with chairman vos and
i actually have an amendment
to my bill i'm basically throwing out
the original language of my bill
and i have new language
that would commence in 2023 january
first of next year
which gives latitude to ds and the
commissioner to identify a study
that's been conducted with generally
accepted scientific principles that
demonstrates an individual
pfas or profound chemical
may cause acute chronic
or developmental health effects as a
result of inhalation exposure
if the study exists in
after appropriate evaluation by ds is
done
that they be given the added latitude to
establish or modify that classification
uh as it relates to ambient air limits
uh for this analyte but in
adding that analyte into their rules of
management
so
i'm happy to address the original bill
but i'm really grateful
for the collaboration that i've had with
des over the last couple of weeks
to
try and find
an appropriate introduction for the
state to begin addressing
air quality as it relates to
pfos chemicals in
the
pro curses that will be happening in the
future
so i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you very much for allowing me to
testify happy to answer any questions
that my colleagues may have
thank you representative boyd for
introducing this bill
and also for
suggesting uh amendment language for the
committee to consider thank you
representative thomas is recognized for
a question
uh thank you chairman votes uh thank you
for taking my question uh representative
uh
did i understand you correctly in your
initial introduction that there are
several other states that have enacted
legislation that their studies or their
only studies i apologize they are
studies that i read there were five
studies that i read that talked about
limiting and i apologize i should
clarify that and thank you for allowing
me to amplify that point there's studies
that were done by those five states that
i had read that was the genesis behind
my bill
follow-up thank you for the follow-up
and so in your speak in your talks with
des
your original bill they said it was
very unmanageable to
deal with poundage and in terms of that
and so they're
you're going to fashion
your amendment to
maybe be more like the other state's
studies
the short answer is yes but it's not to
be like the other states new hampshire
is its own state and new hampshire can
decide what they feel is appropriate in
terms of how the state so
i'll let
kathy um she's here today
um to talk about
where the department stands but
unmanageable is my word that was
i i like to simplify things as as much
as possible that's how that was the word
that i took away from my conversation
with them and it's in honestly it's a
good word it allowed for a lot for me to
circle back and provide
uh alternative language for the
committee's consideration for enactment
thank you
okay by the way before i uh
recognize someone for further questions
did everybody get a copy of the proposed
amendment
if not
raise your hand
okay
apparently
everyone has
received 20. actually
one stuck together representative
okay representative callie pitts is
recognized for a question
thank you representative floyd uh
i i have a couple of questions
portsmouth and i'll ask the first in
portsmouth itself is having pfas
problems
and one of the problems that we're
having is with the turf
and of course that's an emission and
what we
what has been determined
is that it is very difficult
to quantify what's in the air so
and that's that's going on right now we
haven't got the results of studies and
that's going on right now would you i
see the amendment would you um
consider
rather than an amendment which the
committee has to introduce
a commission to study this
again there are studies going on around
the state i understand merrimack's
problem portsmouth had its own problem
cochlear landfill there's all kinds of
things and pfas is everywhere
everything we touch almost has some sort
of pfas in it but it's not all
what i'm told dangerous and
the jury's out
so
would you uh
want to change this to a commission
yes
if that's the will of the committee yes
i'm just saying would you agree with
that that it needs to be studied more
especially quantification
everything that in representative cali
pets
portsmouth and merrimack have been
at the forefront
of being impacted
by
the flowers whether it be in in the soil
or in or in our water and
i'm
i think we're all intimately aware of
what you know what's going on with the
coakley landfill i think new hampshire
is uniquely positioned to take the lead
nationally on this issue if we begin
having the conversation the conversation
needs to happen now it can't be for
my grandkids grandkids and it can't be
for your grandkids great grandkids
representative okay we need to start
having the conversation now if it means
creating a commission so that we can
work with our partners at des to begin
looking at
how how the analytes are impacting air
quality and coming up with some real
scientific data so that this state can
begin to take steps
uh as it relates to air quality then
absolutely i would i would i would
embrace that so whatever whatever the
direction the committee wants to go with
my bill i would be grateful to begin the
conversation with anything follow up
i would like to follow up with a point
and i i understand about saint gobain
coakley and what happened at pease with
the wells at peace what i
what what recently case
was that children playing on an
artificial turf field are also breathing
in
these chemicals
and have you
not only industrial emissions but those
types of emissions and have you come
across that at all in any of your
studies or reading or talking to people
so thank you very much for the question
this is kind of
for me personally
hearkening back to my days on the town
council has nothing
to do
with
pfas per se
but merrimack has a brownfield that
is currently being managed by the epa i
believe and they wanted to give us this
brownfield to put a soccer field on and
i absolutely said no because once you
break the cap of that brownfield and
that begins to leech then you are
potentially exposing whatever was in
that particular brownfield um
you know i mean there's a reason why
there's a captive there's a reason why
it's it's a field it's probably
you know we've we have you know we're
very lucky that we have another
part in town that we were able to
remediate and it's actually a passive
parking town
so
circling back to
the the other brownfield
you know
once that cap is broken it it
potentially can impact the community um
so
very mindful
of
of the exposure that that's that's
involved so while it doesn't relate to
pfas per se it i certainly can
anecdotally relate to
being
having kids being exposed thank you
you're welcome thank you uh
representative mcgee is recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman and thank
you representative boyd for bringing
this bill
um
my question is the bill is exclusively
about about um
pfos in the air
and i know that um considerations i live
near merrimack i'm pretty aware the
water warriors work and the
um the issues that you've undergone in
terms of people's private wells you know
they're on uh
they're on bottled water now many of
them still
because of the contamination there but i
think since you've read all these
when these chemicals are in the air
uh what else do they tend to contaminate
in other words the concern would be not
just that you would be breathing the
particles in from the air and the
percentage of
pifoas that you might you know end up in
in your lungs or whatever from from the
air but that that that air acts as a
current that allows it to drift and
contaminate other things in the
community right so that your your
environment
it's very hard to gauge how much of your
environment would be contaminated is
that correct or that is correct what i
would say to you
anecdotally
as it relates to
my company in town
when
pfas was belching into the atmosphere
unregulated
um if you
look at and i forget the na i want to
say it's the goal of report i think i
think that's the what
ultimately came out of the decree
between saint gobain and ds i think it's
the golden report when they created that
circumference that radius went from a
half mile to a mile
pfas was not being carried
downwind in in out to sea to use a
fishing reference it was dropping like a
lead sinker and it dropped it dropped on
wells four and five it dropped in
litchfield it dropped in londonderry
um and and that's where
um because going from the from the
northwest to the southeast that's how
the winds tend to prevail in that part
of town it makes perfect sense where
where
where the pollutants you know impacted
those water sources
so if you accept if you accept that that
it's dropping like a lead snicker you
know you've got you've got fit you've
got fish that are in the merrimack river
you've got
the merrimack river that now is a result
of on another commission that i belong
to
um
we appropriated monies to penetrate to
put a pump in the merrimack river to
provide an ancillary water source to not
only supplement gun check utilities uh
in in nashua in merrimack but also for
for the new for their new customers in
in litchfield you know when it's
dropping in there and it was being
pumped in they're going in unfiltrated
thankfully you know a lot of the water i
think the water concern is relatively
um address based on what mvd and what
pentachuck is doing to remediate that
specific situation
so long as san gobain is
has their rto online and it's cleaning
the pollutants out of the air i think
there is a relative assurance
that people can have relative not
complete but a relative
assurance
that you know sango bain
is being compliant but as we've seen
they've they just had a
notice of deficiency letter issued by
san gobain because they took that
offline so
you you never know when this company is
going to have to take that rto offline
that's the potential could impact people
downstream so
coming full circle to what you are
saying
yes there is the if if that is if if
saying go being baited and that stuff
gets it's it's going to go downstream
and it could it it may not impact
the drinking water per se as it relates
to mvd or penetrate based on the
precautions and the filtration that
they've put in but you know if we're
talking wildlife if we're talking you
know eating the fish from the merrimack
this certainly could be uh based on some
of the stuff that i've read and in
conversations that i've had with members
in my community that have been very
adept um at this issue from the onset
you know they're they're certainly
long-term health risks to consider
follow-up follow-up
and uh the other question i would ask is
i spoke with
um commissioner scott
in just in the hallway
not too long ago and he mentioned the
fact that there were federal dollars
coming that were going to be assisting
with water cleanup in the state
um i don't know if that's the are for
money or infrastructure money but i
think there was about a hundred million
dollars that was coming to des water
uh that's my understanding yeah so so do
you have any understanding of whether or
not there will be additional cleanup
efforts in terms of being able to
protect the water supplies because i
think that's what that was targeted for
short answer short answer is no i just i
know i know money is coming i just don't
know how it's going to be
distributed
throughout the state
okay thank you no thank you
representative plett is recognized for a
question
this is a clerk question what is an rto
an rto
do you do you have pencil and paper
ready
mr clerk
thermal
oxidizer
so when
san gobain is manufacturing a product
and thank you you're welcome if i could
amplify the point mr chairman yes please
do thank you just for
to educate people they don't know over a
regenerative thermal oxidizer or rto
when san gomez making a product and
they're using
um perforas on their product it
generally gets baked and once it's baked
it goes into it's prepares to go out
this oxidizer covers the smoke stack and
it actually burns
it burns that pea floss right inside the
smokestack so that when
what goes out of the smokestack is
relatively clean of of pfoas and
i think that the temperature gets up to
1200 degrees or 1500 degrees i mean it's
it's scorching it's scorching what they
need to do to burn that off so that's
that's what an rto does
okay thank you representative samsich is
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative boyd i think it's a very
important bill that she brought to us
today
i was a little um
taken aback by the fact that you
mentioned a absolute quantity of 45
pounds
but you didn't say whether that was
per year
per state per site
uh i assumed you
know like this was annually from the
whole state
45 pounds annually is for the whole
state of new hampshire that's correct
okay so
thanks for for clarifying that uh but i
also want to uh mention that because
because i saw that i thought well um you
know we started out with the issue of
water quality and water pollution now
we're getting into the air and air
emissions and as representative kelly
smith
pitts mentioned uh in portsmouth now we
have this issue of a a sports athletic
field that was promised to be non-pfas
which now
is maybe not
non-pfas and so this could happen to
other communities as well and we don't
know how much emission there is and the
fact
don't you agree that the
health effects in general are just not
known i mean i'm i'm in the pfas study
in peace as a placebo group but it's
being done because there are no health
studies yet that are conclusive about
this
have you run into any more studies that
are more conclusive about either water
or air
so there's a couple commissions right
now that are that are addressing the
health of health effects
um department of health insert health
and human services
had a
zoom call last week i think it was
either wednesday or thursday last week
that talked about
um elevated levels of cancer
specif
now i'm drawing a total blank in front
of the committee what kind of cancer it
was there was an uptick
in the specific kind of cancers in the
um
was that in the merrimack area in the
merrimack area that is correct and the
the question
that they knew was going to be asked and
they had already addressed it you know
is is any of the upticks related to san
gobain
and department of health and human
services responded we don't know
so yes we we don't know what the
long-term
health impacts are as they relate to
a pregnant woman you know comorbidities
chronic medical condition cancer we we
don't know
the the either the short-term or the
long-term effects
as as it relates to pfas but
new hampshire thankfully has a couple we
have a couple studies as a consequence
of what happened with with merrimack
beginning to analyze data as it relates
to
health impacts
with with pfas
okay uh you've already asked a couple of
questions so i'll circle back to you
later after everyone else has had an
opportunity and i'll recognize
representative bernardi for a question
thank you mr chairman uh
representative boyd you mentioned uh
five states that are doing studies is
the epa engaged in this at all to your
knowledge
my uh the showing answer would would be
i think so
based on some of the things that i've
that i've researched on i think so i did
not
specifically look at the epa i wanted to
see what individual states were doing on
their own level because i feel if new
hampshire is going to take the lead if
we're going to be independent from
because
i'm going to speak i apologize mr
chairman you know
i have more confidence in what we do as
a state than what the epa
does
and then
part of mine relates to another issue
that has
impacted
basically
storm water issues in my community and
other communities south of new hampshire
i'm not happy with how the
eba handled it and based on that i don't
have a level of trust that that they
might get it right or they might not get
it right i have confidence
in our state and the people that serve
at des that they can help us with this
and begin to take the necessary first
steps to to tackle the issue
thank you not sure if that answers your
question but thank you thank you
representative okay thank you uh
representative knotter has a question
thank you mr chairman and happy birthday
representative thank you for taking the
question representative notter thank you
very much for reminding me i'm 53 years
young so
um first i want to thank you for all the
work that you've done on the town
council since the start of this whole
ugly pfas issue i also don't want to
forget um our late speaker dick hinch
who was working behind the scenes as
well as in the house without any media
kudos
my question is
with so many commissions already would
it be better to just consolidate them
all into one commission to handle
everything air
soil water
the
[Music]
conservative in me would answer yes
the
pragmatic
logical
person in me would say
no because
if you mix air soil and water
it will take
a
longer period of time
to arrive
at the appropriate analysis as what
would need to be done for all three
i think if you target the three
individual
and you specifically give them focus
as it relates to
the toxicity that it does to that
particular mineral
the short-term and the long-term impacts
as it relates
you know to to humans and and animals
and in in in the agricultural piece you
know because
that there is there is a relation there
as well i think
and and you say you might have some
crossover with some people participating
in one participating the other because
you know they're amped up to a new level
of ampedness of wanting to to solve the
problem and i certainly respect that but
if you have in you know three different
commissions with all sorts of different
individuals working collectively on each
individual topic
i think you're able to get to get to
a solution and a direction more quicker
than as opposed to commingling all into
one big large commission and i also you
know quite honestly i would think that a
large commission
handling those three it could become
from my perspective i think it would be
unwieldy
i like the three and candidly i like the
three independent
commissions and if each commission can
have the latitude that they want to do a
subgroup or a subcommittee on a
particular topic you know they certainly
have the latitude to do that
thank you follow up yes thank you mr
chairman um i feel like we've been just
fighting this whole pfas issue for
several terms now could you just remind
us all when this all started what year
it was now you're testing me on that
representative
uh i want to say it is 2016
when
san gobain was testing drinking water at
their plant and they actually uncovered
the issue
i mean our full disclosure they
uncovered the issue
des had a meeting with merrimack and and
that's when the community was notified
by des that san gobain had disclosed
that there was there were there were
pollutants in the drinking water
and
that was you know
last that was the last that's the last
we've heard
okay thank you
before we ask any more questions i would
remind anybody who would like to speak
that we need to see
a pink card to identify you
are there any more questions from the
thank you mr chairman thank you
represent boyd um
i just wondered whether uh during your
your uh
time trying to get a handle on this
issue
whether you also considered
the various uh fire departments national
guard sites that could be using
firefighting foams as we know befose are
connected directly to p to firefighting
foams
at the piezer air base initially but
those are also sites that could be
sources both for
ground or intermission pfas
thank you for the question the short
answer is we we have a fire department
we don't have any other units that are
on site like like in that like like a
national guard unit or an armory in in
merrimack
i want to say and again i'm trying to
draw back on my 10 years of serving on
the town council and numerous
conversations with the fire department i
know at one particular point that they
had foam that did have pfos i know that
they have migrated to a particular foam
that does not contain pfos now when
that transition occurred i i don't know
the answer to your question but i i know
that the fire department has has
eliminated
i shouldn't say limited they have
removed the pfas firefighting phone from
the list of equipment that firefighters
are trained to use when pointing out a
fire
okay thank you any more questions from
the committee
representative callie pitts
this is a public hearing and the public
is involved and not everybody
snuff on all the issues that's the best
way i can put it
uh pfas is a very would you agree that
pfas is a very complicated issue
and that pfas that
that's around us all it's in implants
it's in it's in plants matter of fact in
portsmouth they're saying well maybe
it's not the turf it could be the walnut
shells
you mentioned agriculture that this is
something that really needs to be
defined and that not every
quote unquote
pfas
could be carcinogen and i believe that
one of our colleagues on the other side
of the wall
i don't know if i'm allowed to mention
that person but studied the
is studying or in involved in studying
the cancer cluster in the seacoast so
that this is a very complicated issue
and that
general umbrella of pfas
really has to be broken out into
elements and it needs more study i don't
know if
if that's what you would envision a
commission doing but that's what i would
envision a commission doing
and then
putting back all the information that's
going on all around which local people
have been doing with the cooperation of
the state and
different manufacturers so
is that
anywhere near what you would consider a
yes
pfas is very complicated
i don't disagree i don't disagree with
you on that
um
if somebody can show me
a phos chemical that is not carcinogenic
i i think we we would all like to would
all like to to see that and see the data
that that would support that particular
chemical as not being carcinogenic
i'm targeting
air quality
and i'm hoping that a commission
if if that is the will of this committee
to embark on a commission to
focus on p fox and air quality i think
that is a necessary first step because
then you get because in the context of
having that conversation
as i alluded to in my original testimony
um
inhalation
is is you know
can't even begin to to to
emphasize that you know when you know
inhaling this particular stuff you you
don't know
again short-term long-term health health
effects of it so
the commission i would think would would
hopefully would look at once they've
analyzed
what what air quality is and what's
considered acceptable that they would
attack and again
that it's certainly subject for
compensation that they would tackle the
the health risks that that are involved
with this
um
i know
trying to remember everything that you
said representative and i apologize
um
the one thing that i would would try to
amplify
to you as it relates to
complexity
is
somewhere
right now in a lab it could be mit could
be cal tech could be stanford cornell
you know they're they're making
something new
um and they're doing it in concert with
what they can with chemical company a
that's going to be the latest and
greatest you know people are 2.0 before
2.1 it's like you know your apple ios
updates that we get ever it seems like
you know every week we're getting a new
update from apple on our phone
pfos is the same thing this is going to
be a new update and new update and this
is you know what
we've tried to do in merrimack and the
folks that have been on
you know that and i don't mean to
pontificate mr chairman and to my
esteemed colleagues i apologize i'll be
quick but this is what they've tried to
to amplify to the general public
you ban one chemical they're going to
come up with something new you being
that next chemical they're going to come
up with something new it's just it's one
domino after another and i think
and i have a little bit of a difference
of opinion with des because you know des
is and i agree with what they're doing
you know they're taking a programmatic
approach to to identifying i'm like
we we've got to basically all lumping
into one grocery bag so that work i feel
like we're covering everything and
unfortunately it can't work that way but
i think the more education we do we tell
people
of the potential effects that they could
have not just on on water and fruit but
our our health our animals our pets help
you know i i think we'll be doing
we will be doing
our community a great service by
educating people on that so
thank you for the question
representative i agree
okay
uh further questions for representative
boyd
i have one
referring to your suggested amendment
representative
you use this language you say the
commissioner shall conduct a review to
determine whether there exists one study
et cetera et cetera
why only one study what if there are
could that language be modified in your
judgment so i like i said i collaborated
with des
on on this particular language i
made a small change based on the
recommendation of an attorney from ols
but i
and i can't speak for for kathy and
health and human health health and human
services i apologize uh new hampshire
department of environmental services um
i certainly
if you told me you wanted to see
you know three or four
you know definitive studies
you know whether they be from
state of minnesota
mayo clinic i mean however you want i
mean how i mean not to be facetious but
however you wanted to arrive at that
number i certainly would be amenable to
i think the the concept
of of the language of giving des the
flexibility
to
rely on specific studies that would
allow new hampshire to be able
to be proactive in
managing
uh ambient air quality limits in new
hampshire i think is
the way that i
walked away in with
the way that i walked away with is is
the goal of what the amendment is trying
to do to have des have that flexibility
or i'll get clarification rather on that
question from
ms uh beam when she testifies did i
pronounce that correctly
any further representative thomas
thank you mr chairman uh this uh jogged
me to ask this question so thank you for
taking the question
realizing that the
um the study of the air quality of pfas
and the study of its effects in water
are so closely related
cause and effect if if you will
would you
be amenable if we came up with an
amendment that although we keep those
two commissions separate
that there might be a requirement
that the two commissions would have to
collaborate at some point in time
to collectively go over their
information to see the symbiotic effects
of of the two uh my my fear is that if
you
when you have two separate commissions
they will take on a rice bowl approach
and you know they'll report on their own
but but i see a a potential need that at
some point they would need to
collaborate their information together
and i think putting it into statute
might be a way of ensuring that they
that they share this information
representative thomas thank you very
much for your comments and question and
the answer is yes i think it's a great
idea i think that's absolutely important
okay
any additional questions for
representative boyd
seeing none i thank you representative
for bringing this bill to our committee
and uh for your testimony this morning
we appreciate it mr chairman through you
and again to my esteemed colleagues of
the general court thank you very much
for having my bill today i appreciate it
thank you
so now we'll turn to
uh our next
presenter and i'll call on kathy beam of
the new hampshire department of
environmental services air resources
division
and please miss bm if i mispronounce
your name i
i ask your forgiveness and please give
me the correct pronounce and
pronunciation well thank you very much
representative boys and the commission
committee
it's beam so the h is silent
um
so i just want to come up and give you
some factual information about how the
regulations that we currently implement
at the department work because this bill
and the amendment are part of a
regulation that we already have on the
the bill and the amendment are
language that will be if if approved
would be put into rsa 125 i which is our
state air toxics regulation
it already requires a department using
the similar language
to
create rules that establish ambient air
limits for inhalation standards
for regulated pollutants and we have
over 400 regulated toxic air pollutants
already on a
regulation as a result of this rsa
currently the way that those compounds
go on to that rule is either they're
deemed a hazardous air pollutant or they
have information from the acgih which
i'm sorry i can't remember exactly what
that is but it's basically osha's
you know a committee that comes up with
the compounds that are of concern for
osha exposure
and we as a department
create the limits based on information
scientific and information
so just to put into perspective the
ammonia salt of pifoa was already on our
ambient air list
the company saint-gobain already was
subject to the air already reformula
related back in
2006 as a result of that regulation so
it already was dealing with inhalation
exposure from a particular pfas compound
what i believe this amendment
does is require us to use the same
mechanism
that we already have for other regular
toxic aeroplanes but specifically spells
out pfas and looking for a science that
would substantiate putting more
compounds from pfas
substances on the list so that's
just some context when it comes to air
ex air emissions that impact water we
already have a regulation it's called
rsa 125 c
10e and we'll go into the details but
that is the
backed best available control technology
rule that required saint-gobain to put
on the regenerative thermal oxidizer to
control air emissions so they wouldn't
impact water so we again have another
regulation that already deals with
air emissions that impact water versus
this one which is inhalation standards i
just wanted to put that into perspective
and then the other comment i wanted to
make is that when saint cobain was
emitting large amounts of pifoa back in
2004 2005
just pifoa we're talking about it was
around 800 pounds a year the
reformulation brought them down 96
reduction as a result of this air toxics
regulation
and now after measuring their stack test
emissions back in september
49 compounds 49 p-fast compounds
uncontrolled would be about 17 pounds a
year and controlled her at 2 pounds a
year so i just want to put everybody
into that perspective it was around 900
it's
for one compound we're now down to
controlled emissions of 49 compounds at
2 pounds a year which is why the
department was a little concerned about
the 45 pounds per year across the state
we weren't quite sure where it came from
so
i'm you know just providing information
for the commission our committee sorry
well thank you we appreciate that
information it's
very important to uh
to our decision-making process
and i suspect we number one want to
thank you for being here to testify and
to answer questions and i suspect there
will be quite a few
questions for you
uh representative thomas is recognized
thank you mr chair a very simple
question uh
what you just presented us is that a
written testimony that you provide to us
it was very technical and and number
oriented we'd like to be able to read
that sure
um is it possible for me to provide that
in an email later i don't have it
written up i just yes yeah please do
thank you
email would be fine thank you
uh representative mcgee is recognized
for a question thank you mr chairman and
thank you for your testimony miss beam
um you mentioned that when you last
measured at st cobain in september
um my question is around uh
you know we're talking about quantifying
in terms of how we categorize what we're
looking at so that we understand what it
is and what category it should be in in
order to be regulated
but then the other piece of that is the
enforcement so i wonder if you could
tell us a little bit about how
how we get a handle on it in terms of
being able to interact with the
companies who might be
leeching this either from their air you
know air stacks or or through water
how that piece happens and
you know how well you think you're able
to keep on top of the enforcement piece
of whether people are actually complying
with the regulations that we have in
place
well thank you very much for your
question
as it pertains to saint-gobain they
already have an air permit and so we are
already well you know very familiar with
the facility we have requirements for
monitoring record keeping reporting we
can inspect at any time we have
inspected um
recently we do
you know do inspections and enforcement
for those facilities and others that may
fall into that category
um when it comes to very small sources
they're still required to comply with
the state or toxics regulation and many
times that's a
self-monitored type of situation if if
you look at this rsa 125 i where this
bill is proposed
that requires us to write regulations
and it imposes requirements on sources
but in terms of actually having to have
a permit or going through us and being
evaluated
it's more of self-imposed on the
companies unless they're already in the
system but we can request that
information at any time and they are
required to to keep that information if
they determine that by evaluating it
they need a permit to limit their
operations they're required by the rule
to to contact us
so i mean that's just
the structure of the law itself and
follow-up
follow-up thank you
um i know that in my town north hollis
uh several folks have received notices
from des that they wanted to
test their wells for potential pfast
contamination and they and it was found
in those wells in north hollis
um but the source wasn't saint cobain it
was another um it was determined to be
and this is this is the rumor that i
heard i wasn't really involved in the
conversations but
um another manufacturing plant that was
over by the walmart facility in amherst
and so i guess my question is when you
talk about a large company you may have
more insight into them because they
actually have resources
to devote to
making sure that the state is able to
get what information it needs and so
that they might have more
insights into what's going on in their
company
do you have any knowledge of of other
smaller
manufacturing
facilities around the state like the one
that i'm referring to
that are having
additional
impacts on folks in the area in terms of
pfas because i know that it's not widely
known but i think
the water piece is spreading
ms beam before you answer that question
uh representative mcgee i would caution
you to
be very careful about making an
accusation
against a company
that could be identified based on your
description
without evidence
based on rumor i i don't think that's a
an appropriate thing to do so i'd ask
you to be very careful about that in the
future i think yes involved in in the
discussions with the people in my town i
just don't remember the name of
okay miss beam if you have any knowledge
or if you want to comment feel free
otherwise
if you don't want to comment that's fine
too
the the only comment i can say is that
um
i'm not involved with water and and the
remediation efforts going on around the
state so i can't really speak to that
particular situation what i can speak to
is our investigation of the air side of
any of the companies in the in the state
in 2016 when the saint-gobain incident
was
discovered
we made a list of potential facilities
based on their type of operation and
based on what we know about pfas at the
time and so we had a list of companies
that we did further investigations
inspections
surveys and whatnot so we do have a list
of those
there haven't been a large number of
companies identified to the level that
saint cobain was okay thank you
thank you representative pled is
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question miss beam
in all of my spare time up here well uh
in between keystrokes i went on the web
and i'll ask if you think that acgih
might stand for american conference of
governmental industrial hygienists yes
thank you for that clarification
representative callie pitts is
recognized for a question
thank you
um
as i mentioned before the the
there is another pfast situation going
on
and
in portsmouth and one of the one of the
involvements is
or one of the
concerns is that children are playing on
a field that is artificial and that
somehow this pfas
gets released
and children are breathing it as well as
coming in contact with it
is there any way that and that's a small
thing but when you're dealing with
children it's not so small
is there any way that the
division of air services can monitor
what's coming out of that field what
emissions are coming out of that field
because
we were told or advised up until now
that that's almost impossible to do on
that level because of the pfas that
surrounds us
in regular life
so
can can the this
large emissions
are probably easier to
quantify but how about the small
emissions we could be which could be
just as dangerous if done on a regular
basis can you do that now or is that
thank you for your question
representative i'm sure
um there are various ways to measure air
concentrations in air
one is to do a stack test right at the
facility and collect the information
directly from the vent which is the most
accurate because you know where it's
coming from and you have methods to do
so that's what we've done at st cobain
the other way is to monitor background
information and put monitors around the
facility so in the case of saint gobain
we've asked them to do some rainwater
studies looking at wet deposition
and what's collected in rainwater and
there have been some studies nationally
that have looked at rainwater and then
there is another method where you can
get ambient dry deposition it's much
more difficult to actually get
substantial amount of information from
that or even to be able to pinpoint
where that background information you
know concentration is coming from
many of the studies i've read about
background dry deposition or dry
concentrations have been in picograms
which is an order of magnitude lower
than what is measured or what is of
concern
from from an inhalation point of view
but
again there haven't been that many
studies on breathing it in
at those lower levels
mostly it's been about children in terms
of getting it on their hands with dust
and
ingesting it and that's why the
standards are primarily related to
drinking water or perhaps with with dust
and and that sort of thing but there are
not been that many studies done on
inhaling it especially at those very low
levels
follow-up
what what you just said about the dust
and inhaling it and and getting it on
their skin and as well as inhaling it
if children are playing and on a field
that
could that be a problem in your mind and
would it
come to the attention of the des
and then if that field does prove to be
a problem
have we
so i i don't think we have enough
information to be able to comment on
that in terms of both exposure or in
terms of toxicity so i i don't really
have an answer for that
i'm sorry
thank you uh representative samsung is
recognized
thank you thank you mr chairman and
thank you miss miss beam
um
i i want to kind of uh
hook on to the comment that
representative was making before about
the symbiotic relationship
between representative thomas about
water and air
and we just heard
from representative mcgee about the
issue with well water
so i know that you're now
you've got limits on air emissions and
you have identified the primary source
for this in the state at least here in
new hampshire
but what is the role of des as far as
remediation i mean this plant has been
emitting this large quantities for many
many years
and that has had an impact on the
environment around us and perhaps even
health effects
and that could include well water in the
vicinity of the area
so what is ds's role in trying to
mitigate any harm that was done in the
past
in the interest of time i really can't
go through all of the things that are
going on with the remediation efforts in
merrimack but i can say that um there is
a huge site investigation going on in
the waste division i primarily work in
the air side of things so i would be
remiss in trying to answer all of your
questions regarding what's going on in
that area
but
again
that information or that that evaluation
is being done by the waste division
so
i don't know if i can exactly
cover everything that they're doing
it's not my area of expertise
okay thank you representative thomas is
recognized for a question uh thank you
mr thank you for taking my question um
much to my knowledge
of all the compounds that can be
combined into the general pfas category
i believe there's a five i believe that
are considered the most concerning at
this time so i was wondering and correct
me if i'm wrong but so i was wondering
in your testing particularly of of the
air
does one test fit all or do you have to
do
numerous tests for each and every
compound
thank you for your questions so
stack testing we get the sample but we
can analyze now for up to 50 pfas
compounds from that sample
and those 50 do cover all of the
compounds that have an ambient
groundwater quality standard in the
state of new hampshire as well as 45
others or actually 46 others i guess so
yeah we can we can get it from one
sample
okay uh representative bernardi is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman uh thank you miss
beam um
with respect to setting and ultimately
setting a standard that
is described in the amendment or
potentially commission coming up with
this
it's my understanding that typically two
adequate and well-controlled studies are
the
the basis for setting a particular
standard i'm i'm trying to understand
why one was selected here
thank you for your questions so
in drafting the amendment uh the
department took the existing language
that's in rsa125i
that
that requires us to set rules based on
one standard if somebody um brings that
to our attention so i just used we just
used the same language that was already
in there for the regular
regular toxic air pollutants in the
previous section of the law so it was
just a consistency more than a
you know an up-to-date way of
defining how that study should be
evaluated
follow-up
then is it appropriate in some future
bill to change that standard to
two for the future
thank you representative pementel is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you ms bean
uh
there's
this conversation is going a couple ways
one is towards the
amended bill and the other is to a
commission
commissions are always very informative
and give us a lot of answers that we
don't already have
that being said
is there any reason why we shouldn't go
forward
with an amended bill
just to keep things
again i would leave that up to the
committee i i don't have an opinion one
way or the other in that regard
certainly if you if you did the
amendment
it would require us as a department to
look at the studies on an annual basis
and at least be doing that
it could be done in conjunction i
suppose with the commission but
follow-up
uh thank you mr chairman ye i guess
essentially
um
i guess i'm not asking
if you think it's a
good idea i guess i'm asking
do you think it's
not prudent
to
pass this amended version
if
we're also going to do a study committee
or a commission
well i guess i'm unclear what the
commission's purpose is if they're
looking for a study and doing the same
work then maybe it isn't prudent but if
they're doing further evaluations of air
inhalation issues i i'm not completely
sure what the commission's proposed to
do so
okay thank you representative cambrils
is recognized for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you miss
bean uh you mentioned earlier that most
of the small industrial companies
self-regulate or
self-monitor
at what point or what is the threshold
for them to have to get a permit like
sangobain
thank you for the question um so there
are different requirements for permit
to get a permit some of them are
separate from
the
regulated toxic air pollutant rule some
of them are because of the size of a
boiler or in terms of the emissions of
all the organic compounds in general or
particular process so there are lots of
reasons to get a permit for that
particular law and the rule that applies
to it what it basically says is that you
have to comply with these ambient air
limits and if you cannot do so with
uncontrolled
uh emissions allowed you know throughout
87 60 hours a year and you need to take
some sort of limitation either in
throughput or hours or whatever you have
to come and ask for a permit that
limits you to that that's that's how the
rule is structured
okay
additional questions for miss beam
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman thank you miss
bean i just want to follow up again on
this question of one study
uh if i read if i read this
amendment correctly it almost sounds
like
you need to conduct a review and if you
can just find one study
that shows some kind of cause of chronic
illness or so forth
why not
identify all studies including the ones
that show no
no negative effects or why is just one
study required it almost sounds like we
need to kind of sift through the studies
and find one that we like and we pick
that one and we ignore the others that
probably is not a good way of doing
things
thank you for the question so
initially the department had suggested
that there be language that it would be
upon the term determination by the
department about the study so that we
could evaluate the scientific validity
of it um
but that was a little too ambiguous so i
think it was recommended to remove that
um
you know again the language was exactly
what was in the previous section four of
that law that says we do the same thing
for regulated toxic air balloons now
have we had very many people come and
bring a study to us to get a compound on
the list no
so it hasn't probably been vetted as to
the level that it may imply but
um
so we were just using the language
that's already in the law for other
pollutants for this particular case so i
defer to the committee on whether that
should be
changed or broadened or whatever you
choose
thank you
sounds like a matter for discussion at
some future date
any further questions for
seeing none i will thank you miss beam
for coming this morning to testify
before the committee we appreciate your
insights and your data
and i would like also like to thank
representative boyd for bringing this
bill to our attention
as you may have
determined or or guessed
i was expecting a much larger crowd of
people to testify on this bill so that's
why i originally scheduled this hearing
for two hours
and uh i'm a little bit surprised that
we had so few people interested given
the
the importance of this particular
subject and and
the number of discussions that are being
held about it um
but so be it that's the way it is uh
and so
uh i'm going to close the public hearing
on house bill 1546-f
n
representative mcgee did you have a
question yes mr chairman thank you um
are we going to review the blue sheet i
i know people may not have been signed
in here but we may have had online folks
so
yes representative pementel would you
retrieve the blue sheet and
give us a
you can just read it you don't have to
okay thank you and thank you
representative mcgee for reminding me to
announce the results of the flu of the
blue sheet mr chair yes representative
thomas thank you for clarification does
uh uh representative pimentel does that
mean that there were in terms of the
blue sheet they were zero pro one con
uh rep
kristen
do you know how to get the results of
representative partial maybe you know
something about this
she does and so do i and i already have
it here so i'll save you the trouble
we have
eight people in support of this bill
in opposition
and no neutrals
okay thank you
at some point we'll need a a description
of how to retrieve that information
for all of us representative knotter has
a question
thank you mr chairman do we have any way
of knowing who the people are that sign
in online where they come from from if
they're even in new hampshire
good question christian do you know the
answer
could you come up to the table and use
the microphone to give us the answer
thank you
i'm bringing my laptop because i don't
always remember well enough without it
on the general court website under the
house homepage
oh i'm sorry
usually i'm thinking the same thing when
people are talking okay
on the
general court webpage for the hou the
house home page
meeting information which of course now
at the bottom oh yes okay so if you go
under actually forget about meeting
information because that's what i was
looking for before but representative
partial is correct if um when there's
the blue uh menu bar
where you can see
committees and there's a drop down where
you can look up standing committees
statutory and study
you can look at online testimony
submissions
and if you click on that
you can select a committee
and then once you select a committee you
can select a bill
and obviously you select a bill and that
will bring up um
a list of um what was this what's his
bill number one
1546. okay thank you
so if we look at 1546 i won't repeat the
numbers but um
on this one it doesn't look like there
was any online written testimony but if
there was you'd see a pdf link
so you can see it from there and
hopefully that will um
i don't know how people feel about the
emails but the the idea is fewer emails
to the committee email address
but otherwise it it should be on here i
had one pdf that i didn't i clicked on
and it couldn't find it so if anybody
runs into that with something
you can let us let me know and i can try
to find out what's going on with that
but it should work it should be when
people submit the online
submissions so again that's from the
house homepage
under committees at the in the blue menu
bar
online testimony submissions that's also
where people can find the option to
submit their own testimony
so i think representative notter was
asking a question about the online
version of the blue sheet
okay
that's essentially it it's just either a
blue it's all one list and if they
submitted written testimony
it will also have a pdf
but that this also shows position
supporter opposed
representative partial
yes thank you and thank you kristen for
being so
thorough
there is one thing i think to answer
representative knotter's question
i don't know how to access
where these are from i know when i weigh
in on a bill myself they ask me my town
this information is not getting through
to this page
i don't know if we can back up i think
would be an excellent thing to know
where these people are weighing in
from but i
and i know the information is available
i'm just not seeing it
get through to this level and i think
it'd be an excellent suggestion for
whoever
enters this information if you could
find some way to do crystal as well you
i do know how to get to a different
version of the of the blue sheet if
we're still using it so i'll find out
and what i can do is
that these don't close until midnight
tonight
so what i can do what i've been doing um
or what we've been doing is they'll go
in the file after it closes so you know
tomorrow morning for example i can print
out a different version that will have
at least their
email addresses i think let me see
i can look at that up if you want to
representative knotter did you have a
follow-up
yes oh thank you i recognized ten of the
names some of them are state reps or
they they used to be
one is a a lobbyist and
one but the rest of them
we don't know who they are i mean how do
we know that they're not
typing in from california or some other
state right
right um this is what i'm looking at now
so
i just don't know how
you can get to it i just happen to have
a link and i don't know if that's
something
that will work for everybody or if it's
something i
somebody shared with me
but i do have that information um so i
do have people's towns and email
addresses and their positions so i can
get that to the committee um i could
send it to the clerk um or i can just
however you want me to deliver it i can
get that but we generally will do that
the day after the hearing because
it's
they can still submit their opinion
um through and after the hearing and up
until midnight tonight um i will say
there's another committee um uh
commerce uh they asked me to print it
the day of just so that they know where
it stands at the time which i'm happy to
do
that would be useful sure it might also
be useful for you to speak to the folks
in committee services to ask if they
could
figure out a way to make this to get
that to you data available online so
that it could be easily accessible we
have a whole bunch of folks who want to
make a comment about this
representative thomas thank you i i
agree with you i i i is my desire to
follow commerce's um
way and and have something in writing
for our public hearing at least
we know where we stand at that time i
think it'd be very helpful yeah
absolutely i can do that
um other comments representative callie
pitts yeah i you know i i guess where
people are coming from
is important but i have never heard or
understood that there was a rule that
limited testimony to new hampshire
residents we usually give precedence to
new hampshire residents
and how we weigh it is up to us
but testimony can come in from anywhere
as far as i know so where it comes from
if it's a legitimate source
an expert source or whatever i i don't
think that's
relevant
okay uh
representative nader did you have a
further comment um yes and i i
understand uh what the representative um
means because uh you're right we have
people that fly in to testify but um
last year the reason i was wondering
about this where they're from is because
last year we just had this unreasonable
amount of numbers coming in these people
signing names and just hundreds of them
from from where
and we didn't know and it was just a
ridiculous amount
okay uh
representative stop said you have a
question yes thank you mr chairman i
actually i i want to just
underscore what uh
representation said about uh that every
anyone can submit testimony to us just
like they can come in and sign the blue
sheet the big difference is
on the blue sheet we know who they were
and where the where they live or where
they come from it's it's okay to make
testimony from anywhere but we should
know that when we're when we're hearing
a bill and if it's a hundred people
signing in and 50 of them are from out
of state they can do it but we should
know that so it would be good to have
that documented
so kristin anything you can do to help
us get that information would be
gratefully appreciated i can get you if
you want i can run up and get the print
out of what i just did but the numbers
are
i can get that for you either way um i
can go get that now and i will get you
the ones for this afternoon
um
it looks like there will be a time for
me to do that by 12 30. so that would be
appreciated thank you i know last year
we got that print out
before our public hearing started now
the sign ends
yeah in the morning or the night so this
is so it's different this year because
we allow
sign-ins until midnight right but
nevertheless if we could have some sense
of what the online sign-ins looked like
during the public hearing that would be
that would be useful representative
partial
thank you again for taking my question
chair
uh we were having a discussion about
this very thing when the sign-in cuts
off
and
one of the questions that i had is why
can't we have the sign ins cut off
on the day that we exec the bill
that will be able to get the broadest
sample possible of people who like to
either support or oppose the bill
i don't know why we have to sign off on
the day
the hearings close
and if you have i mean
this could be a rhetorical question or
it could be a serious question i don't
know
maybe kristen you could ask committee
services why they chose to do it the way
they're doing it today and uh bring us
an answer sure
at your earlier if i can get one
absolutely okay
thank you no problem
any other comments or
okay see none thank you kristen we
and unfortunately it looks like we're
going to have a extended lunch break
we will resume here
at 12 30 for the public hearing on house
bill 1270
which is a bill to dissolve the
legislative oversight committee to
monitor the transformation of delivery
of electric services
so we'll see you back at 12 30 and enjoy
your long lunch break
representative callie pitts did you have
yes it's officially closed thank you
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the continuation of our
february first session
before we get to our first public
hearing which will be on house bill
1270.
representative plett has some
information to share with you about our
last public hearing representative plett
thank you mr chair i've been given the
public opinion signed on through website
the equivalent of the blue sheet for all
of the bills today including the one we
just heard now they could change because
we have until midnight people have been
until midnight tonight to put it in but
the results so far
on the last bill uh was this support
nine opposed 34 and all of these are
from new hampshire
okay
thank you for that
that update and uh we'll look forward to
getting a similar update
when we
finish the public hearing on this bill
so without further ado i would like to
announce or like to introduce the
sponsor of house bill 1270
which is a bill an act dissolving the
legislative oversight committee to
monitor the transformation of the
delivery of electric services
and i would like to
give to the floor
representative thomas the prime sponsor
to explain this bill to us
thank you mr chair thank you
members of the committee and good
afternoon
very simple
language uh we don't need this bill uh
this commission anymore the original
intent of this commission
was to oversee the um
uh
the change in the in the utilities to
divest themselves of their of the energy
producing
plants they had and that was completed a
couple of years ago
there was an attempt to perhaps change
the
purpose of this committee but in reality
there's been no meetings held on this
commission for
at least a year and a half
there really is i see no need for this
commission to exist any longer we have a
lot of others coming after us here for
other purposes that are far more
pertinent and important
so my my recommendation is that we just
repeal this committee and allow room for
others to take place that are going to
be much more
important for the you know coming times
that's that's all i have to say
thank you
thank you representative thomas for your
testimony on this bill are there
questions for representative thomas
representative flett is recognized for a
question yes thank you i'll just point
out a minor edit you might want to
consider
with uh
on page on line four and five we
scratched out to the legislative
oversight committee to monitor the
transformation deliver electric services
established under iris whatever the word
two got struck out you need it
so so it should so the two should stay
in there so beginning in 2009 to the
house science technology energy
uh thank you for the question and yes i
agree we can undo the strikeout of the
t.o
i think that's all okay uh
representative callie pitts is
recognized for a question
representative thomas having served on
that committee
for
some years
uh
nothing has met for a year and a half
we've been kind of dormant for a year
and a half
and it's very hard to get it together
but the purpose i think of this
committee
was to
be able to independently call
a study on a particular issue or delve
into an issue that needed to be
delved into i don't know if you were
here when the committee was very active
but we would bring quite a few experts
in to talk to us from the and they would
come
because they were very interested in
what the oversight committee had to do
for recommendations and reports
in the last few years i understand it
waned a little bit and then in the last
year and a half you know everything's
gone but i i think that it's very
important to have a committee
that can be independent of this
committee
and not bring
20 people in
but be able to keep pulse on issues that
are important and the same way that the
science and technical committee can we
can put
refer things to
the electric oversight committee
representative would you say
representative
okay would you say that this committee
if it stays on the books
is costing any money
or doing any
well thank you for the question i'm a
firm believer that if nothing is
happening with something that's
established that we
shouldn't have it because what one thing
is that if these are on the books we
still have to assign people on that
commission or or committee that takes
some valuable resources
and it's just it's just another one of
the over 400
committees and commissions that we have
here in the state which are very
difficult to fill all of them and some
of them in fact have been around for a
long long time we keep wondering why
they're still here
i just believe that if there is a
special
presentation that has to be made this
committee could certainly invite those
people to come here and make a special
presentation we don't have to have have
a committee for that
so as an answer to your question is
why keep something on the books when we
really don't have a useful use for it
and the original intent of it really has
gone away so
that's that's why i'm proposing this
bill
representative callie pitts i'm going to
let you follow up but i will remind you
that we're here to ask questions not to
debate or discuss this issue
well
the other the other thing i would say is
in your opinion
would it be more expensive to have a
committee
of 20 or 21 people come in
or 22 people
than have a subcommittee
of five or six come in to delve into
some of these issues that really take
time
well i don't know what issues you're
talking about but and thank you for the
question because
if there was a special issue that came
up
and this committee is already meeting on
a day where we maybe have an extra hour
uh we're already being paid for coming
here for that day so we might as well
hear a one-hour presentation on on on
some issue i don't think we need to have
a special subcommittee to to to delve
into a to a
a special interest that that wants to
come in here so again
i'm looking at all the committees we
have on the books and a lot of them
haven't met in well over a year
this is one of them and we have all the
committee i mean i'm on the offshore win
commission which is very valuable right
now we have the easy board that's very
valuable um i think we we have enough
mediums
involving this this type committee
than to have one that's been sitting
dormant for a while
representative mcgee is recognized thank
you mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question
um when i look at the bill it
your description makes it sound as
though this i think what you're saying
is that this was a result of the
restructuring so it was it was
originally put together in order to sort
of deal with the questions that came
with a restructured energy market
but in the language of the bill itself
there are sections and the first section
um
is the renewable energy fund
and there's always a lot of questions
around that and then
pollute pollutant reduction program
carbon dioxide emission budget for those
trade programs so it seems like there
are a lot of other discussion items here
that have come out since
restructuring happened so we may not
need what we needed back then
but i don't think the
issues that are even listed here uh as
being part of the purvey of that
committee
are gone so
is there a question here yeah so the
question is
you're saying we don't need this
committee and i'm saying
do you have a description of the
questions that this committee would be
concerning itself with today
because it doesn't seem like energy
questions have gone away in terms of
needing
people who are overseeing them
thank you for the question
my opinion is we don't need this
committee if we want to talk about a
particular issue that's coming up in
today's you know trending issues we
certainly could arrange time during this
committee to hear a presentation and i
think the proof in the pudding is the
fact that
no one has seen fit to call a committee
meeting of this nature for well over a
year and a half
and i don't believe keeping things on
the books
just in case something was to happen is
a good way to manage business here like
i said we have a lot of commissions and
committees that are kind of in the same
boat
and i think you'll see other bills
coming through that are trying to just
clean up
a lot of these committees that just
haven't seen a need to meet even those
there may be issues out there there are
other ways to uh deal with them this
committee isn't one of them
do you need a follow-up
i would love to but i don't want to
argue with the witness because i don't i
don't see it that way
i don't see that there's another forum
for this to be happening so
i would just disagree with the
conclusion but i don't think i have
another question that would lead me
anywhere thank you thank you
uh representative bernardi is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chair uh
rep representative thomas uh the
the bill calls for an annual report uh
the first of october has has there been
an annual report last year or the year
before
i'm not aware thank you for the question
i'm not aware of the year before but
there wasn't one last year to my
knowledge
at least there hasn't been one presented
to this committee
and i doubt that there'll be one this
year as well
i think a point that can be made is
up until last term this
committee was the purpose of this
committee was for the restructuring
and
there was a bill passed to kind of
change the intent of this committee
because they didn't want to you know
i guess people didn't want to not see
each other again but but
but after that was done
nothing was ever held and so i just
don't see a reason for having a
commission if something if if a new
commission wants to be made for a
specific issue then perhaps a bill can
come along next year to propose one but
this one here i think is it's it's
run the length of its life i think it's
time to retire it and just go on to you
know newer things
thank you
follow up no
all right uh representative uh samsic is
recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative thomas um just to be
clear um
can you explain to me in your own words
what you perceive as being the real
purpose of this oversight committee that
we're trying to get rid of now what was
its initial real purpose i know we've
heard okay here and there but
it's an oversight committee so what was
it overseeing
specifically
well thank you for the question
and i only have my own words so i will
i i will say that uh when i first came
in here they were still talking about
how the divestiture was going to
ultimately
uh play out and that was and what i
heard time and time again
for the few years i was here at first
was that
that they that was why it was formed the
researcher happened
sale was made we're well into a
post-divestiture
era and so uh
the purpose of this original committee
was served they they did the oversight
it was done uh there's no more
divestiture to oversee
and to extend the life of this committee
for other reasons that might come up
this is just a housekeeping as far as
i'm concerned and like i said if there's
a specific purpose
next year that they see that we have to
have a committee they can certainly
propose one for that specific purpose
but
i think this like i said this commission
this committee has run its course and we
just get it off the books so we can go
on to other committees
follow up
thank you mr chairman
just a quick question on page two
uh can you explain to me the
the two repeals that are done there what
what is being repealed there
i have to admit thank you again for the
question i uh be because of the
nature of of i was here during the
original part of the bill
i don't have that in front of me if you
could
relate what those two repeals are it
might chug my memory yes well one one
says relative to
the oversights committee to monitor the
transmission of delivery of electric
service
and the other one is um
oversight commitment to monitor the
transformation of the delivery of
electric service
to the public utilities commission
and the department of energy so
um
i'm not sure how that repeal affects
things
is that well i thank you for the
question i i in this particular case i
believe there is a department of energy
person here that is going to follow me i
would defer that question to that
department
okay thank you
further questions for the bill sponsor
representative plett is recognized yes
this is a clerk question
uh
divestiture
divestiture of what was that the
separation of generation generally from
the utilities or was that specific to
seabrook
uh thank you for the question uh your
first
intent was correct it was the visitor of
all electrical generating stations from
utilities in this case you know
plant that belonged to a utility was
divested and put to the general private
market
thank you
okay representative pementel is
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman uh
thank you representative thomas
for answering our questions um
i i see that basically the all you're
doing is taking
out the legislative oversight committee
that's easy to understand
but
the house science technology and energy
committee are still in there
the senate committee
and natural resources committee are
still in there
and
it looks like we were supposed to see a
report on october 1st of this year
and i'm not really sure
if that ever happened and there was also
someone was supposed to do a report by
june 30th
um
i'm i'm just wondering
um do you know why any of these reports
weren't done is there
somewhere and somebody in the loop was
wasn't uh
calling these reports or making sure
that they're done
thank you for the question if you're
referring
to the part where there were other
agencies that were originally providing
reports to the oversight committee
the answer is
since i no longer think we have the
oversight committee's purpose
those reports were
should have come straight to the science
and tech committee as i think the
original bill had in there
i can't speak for other
agencies that may or may not have you
know given reports yet that that would
follow-up
um i i
guess well i guess i'd like to know um
why we're not getting these reports and
i'm wondering if you
have the knowledge to know
uh
whose responsibility it was to get these
reports to us
so that we can
we can get them right
obviously the legislature wanted us to
have them
so
where are they
thank you for the good question uh
if
those reports are
that from other agencies are supposed to
be sent to the chair of the science and
tech committee if we didn't get them
it would be up to us to go back and find
out where they are but with everything
going on as was so eloquently stated
before
i'm sure there are some things that may
have fallen through the crack but i
think that's something that we could
check on as to why we haven't gotten
some of those reports
representative plett is recognized for a
question could it be that the reports
would have no content whatsoever because
nothing was
uh transpired yeah
well thank you for the question if i had
every if i had to re write a report on
to this on this existing commission that
we're trying to eliminate
my words would have been no action in
renewable energy fund
report was sent to this committee by
august 1st
of this year every member of this
so that one
in particular i know we received we also
received a report
about reggie which is
section four of the bill
the only one i'm unsure about would be
section two of the bill multiple
pollutant reduction program
i don't
remember off the top of my head if we
received a report from from that uh
organization but it's likely that we did
you can all go back and review your
inbox to see
what kind of goodies might be residing
there
representative callie pitts is
recognized
a real question because my by i guess
i'm
over the last 18 months
you know things have been a little
hectic who is the chair of this
that's appointed by the speaker do you
do you know who that is yeah thank you
thank you for the question yes i am
you are
may i follow
representative thomas in the last 18
months have you called a meeting of this
committee
thank you okay any further questions for
representative thomas
representative
harrington is recognized
mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh representative thomas as the
chair of this commission committee do
you see any need to keep it going
uh thank you for the question i do not
thank you
additional questions representative
mcgee is recognized thank you mr
chairman
okay this is this is interesting
um
from what the uh chairman just mentioned
about the two reports that we did
receive
um
it sounds as though these are reports
that we do
actually rely on and expect to recede
receive in terms of the renewable energy
fund and what has happened in the
preceding year and also the regional
greenhouse gas initiatives information
and what has happened in the preceding
year so how will that be accomplished
if
if there is no oversight
with members of the legislature at the
helm
well thank you for the question i
believe
i previously stated that those reports
are sent directly to the chair of the
science and tech committee and certainly
they're send out to everybody on the
committee for their information in my
time on this committee
i do not recall any time where any of
those reports
have been discussed or brought up in
i just don't remember any time
so i think it's handled by the fact that
they're sent to everyone and for their
information to use and
for them to uh
to to read but i don't believe there's
any action required on this committee to
to actually review those reports and
make a comment on them here unless
someone feels a need to but
that's a follow-up no need
follow-up so if this goes through and
the and this language is repealed then
do we stop getting those reports
thank you for the question i i don't
believe if you if if you're reading the
the amendment to the bill or the bill as
as as amended those reports
were being forwarded to the oversight
committee and to the chair of science
and tech
the biggest amendment that i made on it
was there was one there was one report
that was not being sent to the chair of
science and tech and i added that to
ensure that all those reports were being
sent to the science and tech committee
for everyone to see here so you know
nothing would be lost by by repealing
this committee nothing would be lost
those reports would still be sent to
every member of science and tech
thank you just to clarify
the legislation does specify
that the reports go to
the house science technology and energy
committee it's nothing it says nothing
about going to the chairman okay
except of course that the chairman is a
member of the committee but it should go
to every member of the committee just
point of clarification representative
samsich is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative thomas uh well now that
we know that you you are the chairman of
this oversight committee
and you haven't called a meeting in the
last what
19 months or whatever's
did you notify the members of that
committee that you were planning to ask
to dissolve this committee
and wouldn't
these reports we were talking about
wouldn't that have been material that
you would you would have been normally
discussing in that oversight committee
well uh
thank you for the question
i i would assume that as a chair of
committee it would be up to me to come
up with an agenda
i don't recall
those reports being specifically part of
any agenda in the committee in the
previous times although the information
from them may have been used for
people's information to discuss other
other matters
but i looked at the background
i haven't been the i haven't been a
chair of the
dormant committee for as long as 19
months because i think i i've we've only
been here for a year
uh so prior to my tenure uh the uh there
was a previous chair of that committee
i'm not quite sure who it was at the
time and that there was no zoom meeting
called or any other meeting called on
that committee as well so when i looked
at that background and i looked at the
future
i just saw no need to to have this
committee
the lsr was in public view for quite
some time no one contacted me
voicing any question or opposition to it
and it again is just my opinion that
we have no need for this committee to to
exist and i see no need at this point to
call for one um
because we're dealing with other matters
right now then other and there are other
committees out there that are are
handling things
so
thank you uh
any further questions for representative
thomas representative partial has a
question
yes i hope this does oh thank you uh
chair
and thank you uh for your testimony hope
this is not a tangential question but
being a sophomore here i feel like i'd
ask a very sophomore question and that
concerns
uh griffin roberge's uh testimony uh
written testimony i assume he will speak
to it later
uh
and he has uh pointed out that there is
a house bill 1269
that uh
also addresses the structure of this
same committee
and it's uh they speak of a
restructuring rather than dissolving of
the committee
and i would just
like to
[Music]
if you're aware of that or not i'd like
you to just
call it to your attention and perhaps
you have some thoughts on that
uh thank you for the question uh what i
am aware of is that mr roberge told me
the other day that he would be speaking
on this bill and mentioning that there
were other bills coming that would um
i thought he said it would do away with
this
this and other committees
so uh to fully answer that question i
would ask that you defer that question
to mr roberge when he comes up to speak
i would be glad to do that i just want
to have if you have the opportunity
should you have anything on that thank
you for chair no follow-up
okay uh representative berezni is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative thomas for taking my
question um was the only purpose of this
committee to read the reports and then
provide another report to the governor
and and back to the uh the
department of energy uh thank you for
the question uh no i don't think that
was the only purpose of this committee
uh although it might have been
insinuated today
but uh the
again the main purpose of this committee
was to oversee the divestiture and it
was only in the last term that they
changed the
title and purpose
to cover other matters that they thought
might be coming up which
never materialized in my previous
successor or
or me so
again
it was a future purpose that just has
materialized it's best that we get this
off the books and go on to other
committees like i said we have we have
over 400 out there and many of them
meet only once a year or haven't met at
all so i think i think this is good
housekeeping to make way for better
commissions
follow-up follow-up
so other than generating reports what
other actions could this committee take
right
well i'll be honest with you uh thanks
for the question at this time i if if i
thought there was a burning issue that
had to be discussed in a separate
committee
i probably would have called one by now
but i just didn't see a need for
anything right now
the the fact that the doors are open to
allow for issues to come up
doesn't necessarily mean i'm going to
call a meeting together just for people
to come here and
talk about something that
uh maybe we may be discussing in other
bills or or or other commissions
i know that right now the hot topic is
offshore a win and we certainly have a
commission for that
so
the answer your question is i i just
don't see a need under under this
committee to call one for just the sake
okay thank you
any further questions for
representative mann has a question thank
you mr chairman
i hope to be somewhat up
articulate with this
i thought that
one of the possible futures of
in terms of restructuring might be
that the utilities themselves would take
on
the responsibility to
either
deliver electricity or
deliver energy efficiency services to
customers
there being basically two ways of
meeting demand
and so
this could possibly be a future
uh role for this committee
because you know and it could be
certainly possible that if
it's going to be in but would be in the
utilities hands to decide and to run
both aspects of this
future um
is there a question energy system would
uh
would this committee possible in your
view be a useful place to
to
assign the task of
monitoring
how the utilities are
balancing both of these kinds of ways of
meeting demand
thank you for the question i i don't
know
if we want to have a committee for that
purpose that might not otherwise be
covered by having a presentation by the
utilities in front of us to cover that
one subject but i would also
perhaps think that it might be an
agenda item that could be discussed
with the easy board as well
so
i think there are other avenues that
that we could discuss these
these issues of that nature that these
are not
having a separate commission for a lot
of these things sometimes just it's just
not worth it in my mind when we have
other avenues that we can just discuss
those issues
okay
any additional questions for uh
representative callie pitts is
recognized for a question a question
representative have you ever served on
the electrical oversight committee
not chaired served
thank you for your question uh yes i
have back before the messenger actually
happened
okay can i follow that with a date okay
follow up
uh thank you for the question i i i
haven't been around quite as long as you
have so
no
thank you
it was in my it was in my my first term
i think i was on that board for about
two years
okay thank you uh
i i have a
for the chair
yes
we
nobody
has the experience or the understanding
of what this committee was supposed to
do
and a few years ago
unfortunately i am the older one i
remember
what it was supposed to do and what it
was supposed to be continuing to do
and it wasn't just to do divestiture
when do i get an opportunity to say that
what the history is behind this
committee and what it's supposed to be
doing
well when we have an executive session
we have discussions and that would be an
appropriate time for you to
um
give us a history lesson expound on what
if if you want what's your purposes
so
that would be the perfect time
representative mcgee yes thank you mr
chairman and thank you representative
thomas for taking my question um
i get your point about not having
committees just to have committees but
when you mentioned easy board which i'm
a speaker appointed member of the easy
board
there's also a bill that's going through
to change what the easy board is doing
which means that it would not be an
appropriate place
to have these conversations and i think
that's what i've been trying to get at
is
i'm concerned that there will be an
insufficient place for the issues that
are coming up
uh since the divestiture with how the
electorate markets are being are being
managed in the state
without an oversight committee that's
specifically devoted to that
so i just wanted to mention the fact
that
the easy board has recently been
diminished in its role saying you know
that they shouldn't be doing policy
discussions there and it should be more
about
telling people what energy efficiency
can do and you know so our our role has
recently been changed so that i don't
think
i don't think it would be able to assume
the role of the oversight committee that
that's just my point
so what is the question thank you for
the statement i was just wondering if
you understood that because we did just
have a bill recently that changed in in
549 even the language changed um the
role of the easy board
well i'm not thank you for the question
um i'm not
extremely sure that i want to comment on
someone else's bill
uh what it might affect with with the
easy board but i i will add that at one
time when i was on the the oversight
committee um and as my recollection
comes into full focus i was actually
vice chair of it for one term and i and
i remember sitting through
briefings and i remember the chair
struggled to get people to come up in
brief uh they're looking for things to
breathe at
and when you start having to look and
struggle to bring
people to speak on something because you
have to have a meeting that month
tells me that the life of that
commission has is coming to its end and
i think this commission has come to its
end in that respect and like i said if
there's something if we find that there
is something
needed
for other purposes
i'm sure it can be brought up next year
in a bill to establish a new purpose of
okay thank you representative thomas i
think we've
exhausted the questions of the committee
for you i
really appreciate you introducing this
bill and explaining it to us
mr griffin roberge from the department
of energy for
his take on
uh good afternoon members of the
committee uh for the record griffin
roberge from the department of energy um
i'll try to be a little bit slow in my
introduction until my letter of
testimony reaches its way around the
room
but here just to
provide a note that the department is
neutral on the bill however
should the bill move forward there are a
couple of housekeeping changes we wanted
to suggest or just some observations for
the committee to consider in
starting in
if you're referencing my letter of
written testimony
i guess the department outlines four
observations representative plett caught
a fifth on line four but um on line 16
there's just unfortunately a hanging tee
just a very minor grammatical correction
line 26
this is pertaining to section
3 of the bill
it would require the department of
environmental services and the public
utilities commission to annually report
to various committees on the status of
the implementation of the
regional greenhouse gas initiative or
reggie
should the committee wish to move
forward with house bill 1270 the
department would suggest replacing
commission with department of energy
this is just a simple housekeeping
measure due to the creation of the
department of energy and hb2
a lot of that staff has moved over from
the public utilities commission to the
department so it makes sense to have the
department of environmental services
and the department of energy working
together to create this report
that's one observation
the last one is pertaining to
one of the repeals in section four
that's specifically page two
line six to eight
um as you'll see that repeals um a
statute and i've provided in italics
what the statute actually reads
the statute that's being affected is the
commission and the department shall
submit a report to the legislative
oversight committee that's the focus of
this bill
and it shall concern the results and
effectiveness of the system benefits
charge
i'm not sure if this was in if this was
a mistake or or anything like that but
the department wanted to get some
clarity on that whether or not they wish
to
retain this reporting requirement or
repeal it because
either or there are some kind of other
suggestions we'd make
and that's where the two sub-bullets
come in my written testimony should the
committee wish to retain this reporting
requirement and rename who receives the
system benefits charge report
doe respectfully suggests taking section
16 out of representative harrington's
bill
and just putting that in this bill
because that bill makes a
slight correction it just deletes
commission and
just has the department of energy
handling the report and then just
redirects who the report is submitted to
so we suggested maybe the house science
technology and energy committee and the
senate energy and natural resources
committee
um
if the committee wished to repeal this
reporting requirement there is a
crossover reference in another area of
statute that requires the report be
submitted to the commission of the
department of education so that
reference depending on which way the
committee wishes to go should be
repealed or amended
my final note is as was referenced
there are other bills obviously
affecting this committee working its way
through the legislature there's a minor
reference to it in representative
harrington's bill there's also house
bill
1269 which is
dealing with certain legislative study
committees it repeals some
amends the membership and quorum
requirements of others
as it pertains to the legislative
oversight committee to monitor the
delivery of electric services i believe
that bill as it's written
amends the membership and quorum
requirements of that committee um
certainly willing to answer any
questions you might have i understand if
certainly your head is spinning with
everything i've said
but certainly willing to answer any
questions you might have and that
okay thank you mr roberge for your
testimony on this bill i'm sure we have
some questions that we want to ask
i have a general question before we get
to any specific questions about the bill
the purpose of this
committee originally was to provide
oversight to
restructuring
then it was modified to provide
kind of a general oversight on the
electricity
industry
would the department of energy assume
some of that
oversight of
the electricity
markets
and if so
would an oversight committee to
provide some oversight to the department
of energy be in order
thank you for the question uh mr
chairman um in terms of the first part
of your question in regards to what the
oversight committee looks at now
um its duties were so
initially this oversight committee was
as you said to look at the divestiture
back in 2018 there was a bill put
forward that renamed and refocused the
committee
and turned it into what it is today
if this committee
were repealed i mean the department does
have you know regulatory aspects over
public utilities and the public
utilities commission looks at various
issues as they come up under under
dockets and that type of thing and
people are certainly welcome to take
part in those processes i think it's in
terms of
whether or not you want a specific
legislative oversight committee looking
at this that would be a policy decision
for
um legislators to make
we serve at the i mean we'll provide any
answers to questions that
com that policy makers may have this is
i guess a vehicle
to do that whether or not you guys want
to repeal it or keep it
okay thank you questions for
mr roberge
representative mcgee has a question
thank you mr chair thank you mr roberge
for taking my question um they're just
two small little knits um
do you think the department of
the department of education was put in
here because doe was misconstrued or no
i i i cannot unfortunately represent i
can't speak to the genesis as to why the
department of education is in there i
know and this is my it was my attempt at
brevity in my written remarks is that
in that second sub-bullet is that it's a
little bit more of a
substantial section of statute and i
want to
i just want to paste the certain section
as it pertained to the report
based on my recollection and i don't
have the statute in front of me is that
i think
part of the
report is to look at the effectiveness
of energy efficiency and the use of sbc
funds for
public schools educational institutions
and what have you and part of that is
included in the report so it was
forwarded along to the commissioner of
the department of education
the department of energy has no position
on whether or not you guys want to keep
that reporting requirement or not it's
just if you do go ahead and
repeal
the requirement for the system benefits
charge report that this
other statute should be tinkered with as
well because it's a cross reference okay
and follow-up
follow-up my other net
i think it's interesting that we're
hearing that the system benefits charge
is one of the
current
charges of the of the oversight
committee that we weren't we weren't
made aware of by the sponsor but um you
had also mentioned representative
harrington's bill multiple times and i'm
wondering which bill that is that you're
referring to i'm sorry so that i believe
is house bill 1258 and i'm not speaking
all to
the only part of the bill i'm focusing
on is section 16 of the bill as
introduced okay
thank you
additional questions for mr roberge
representative sausage
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
rubish
since since the the assistance benefits
charge is mentioned here and you say
that if this bill were to pass
that requirement to report on the
effectiveness of the system's benefits
charge would then also
be repealed
is there any other entity that is
looking into the effectiveness of the
assistance benefits charge besides this
oversight committee uh well just to be
clear
based on based on the department's read
is that it does repeal again on line six
to eight on page two it does repeal this
reporting requirement as it reads in my
letter of testimony the puc and the
department which means i believe the
department of environmental services
shall submit a report to the legislative
oversight committee to monitor the
transformation of delivery of electric
services the report shall concern the
results and effectiveness of the system
repealing that
would
would lessen the uh would remove the
obligation for under the existing
language the commission and the
department of environmental services to
produce that report and deliver it to
the legislative oversight committee or
this legislative oversight committee if
the committee wish to retain this
reporting requirement that's why i spell
out my first sub-bullet is we would
suggest taking the language from
representative harrington's bill
and replacing the reference to the
legislative oversight committee with say
the house science technology and energy
committee and the senate enr committee
so that would ensure that the reporting
requirement is retained it just redirect
redirects who it's sent to so it would
be sent to the two legislative standing
committees with jurisdiction over energy
matters
thank you
okay further questions for mr roberge
anyone
we heard today that
wind energy is important and is
important part of our whole process
would you say that
these
various industries
wind
solar
hydro
their proliferation
is a direct result of electric
deregulation
i i would say
in part but certainly you know variety
of other factors i'm sure come into play
man follow-up follow-up would you say
or
could you envision
that an electric oversight committee
should have its hand on the pulse
of the proliferation of these types of
energies and what they do to the
electric delivery system
yeah sure i mean to the extent that
legislators want to be informed that's a
you know in terms of the committees that
they create that's a decision for
okay any further questions for mr
roberge
seeing none
are there any other members of the
public who would like to
to address this committee on this
bill
seeing none i will ask mr
pimentel to check the blue sheet
representative pimentel to see what we
and while he's doing that i'll ask
representative plett to in to read what
online we had 47
one supporting 46 opposing and a check
they're all from new hampshire
okay thank you representative pimentel
okay
with that i will close the public
hearing on house bill
and we will take a break until
1 30
at which time
okay let's get back to work here
i'd like to open a public hearing on
house bill
1148 relative to prohibiting government
entities subordinate to the state
from restricting the types of fuel
sources that may be used for energy and
i would like to call on the bill's
primary sponsor
representative fred plett to introduce
the bill thank you and i have written
testimony passed out to every member of
the committee
and then i passed it to the audience so
i tried it
i tried to do it to every member of the
committee
but with this two-layer system it
sometimes uh gets confusing sorry about
that
they all have them back there
yes they do but uh lee oxenham do you
have oxygen
okay thank you
then shall i begin
yes please begin hb 1148 is designed to
keep municipalities to enact ordinances
from enacting audiences to prevent fuel
types for power production or conversion
determination of this type of estate
responsibility is solely and we have a
site evaluation committee to aid in this
decision
making any kind of power generation or
conversion when proposed no matter what
the nature appears to engender a
negative response whether simply are not
in my backyard mentality or ideology
driving an argument against a particular
technology
and i stress any kind uh solar i think
is opposed sometimes they have
restrictions in at least in
massachusetts antrim wind northern pass
liberty utilities granite bridge 27
miles of natural gas pipeline to be
buried along route 101 from stratum to
manchester along with an epping lng
storage facility a recent examples of
controversial proposals all of which
accept enter and win failed or modify to
something entirely different the site
evaluate
site evaluation committee may still red
light many proposed future projects but
the projects ought not be subject to
death by a thousand cuts at the
municipal level
this bill amends rsa 362 by inserting a
new section 362.9 to prohibit government
entities subordinate to the state from
restricting the types of fuel sources
that may be used for energy as such it
is geared towards energy production or
conversion
it was pointed out to me twice in fact
that sb-86 that passed last session and
now law prohibited restrictions on the
installation of certain commercially
available heating systems and engaging
the services of certain energy providers
i see the subject matter is different
the ssb ssb-86 was prohibiting
restrictions excuse me uh
hb 1148 is prohibiting restrictions on
energy production or conversion whereas
sb 86 that passed last year was
prohibiting restrictions on heating
systems never their language though was
very similar so nevertheless i did go
back to the office of legislative
service to see if the language of either
could be
modified tweaked to uh to cut down on
the overall verbiage in the statutes and
it was told no by ols that sb-86 last
year amended
rsa-155a2 and rsa 674-51
both of which relate to the state
building code the language of the new
section inserted by this bill is
inserted into rsa 362 because of
regulation of energy production so i
confirm my belief they are two different
things and belong in two different parts
of the statute with that i'll open up
the questions
thank you representative plett for your
testimony and for bringing forth house
bill 1148
do committee members have questions for
representative platt representative
harrington is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman they'll be taking
doesn't the present
law i assume you're bringing this up
because the present law you feel is not
effective uh meeting the site evaluation
committee rules and the 362h in
preventing a municipality from blocking
a
uh project let me give you for instance
if it was a transmission project that
was going to go across
uh six or seven different towns
doesn't the present law prevent any one
town there from simply making it
impossible to build it
you're talking one example i'm talking
the generality of any kind of production
any type of conversion so i'm not
certain that the current law covers
everything okay follow up mr chairman
follow up so this would basically then
come uh this bill would pick up the
things that aren't covered by the uh
site evaluation statute meaning
projects like below 30 megawatts which
is not necessarily of jurisdiction over
and things such as that absolutely thank
you
okay further questions for
representative plett representative
callie pitts is recognized
representative plitt would these
projects still have to go through the
permitting process on the state level
like environmental services and epa and
all that absolutely it just would
prohibit a municipality but throwing
from throwing roadblocks in their way
thanks
representative mcgee is recognized real
quick thank you mr chairman
um i'm concerned how
this would affect uh folks who are
already following a sort of a net zero
planning for their cities i know we have
towns and cities that did that at our
behest
so there are currently
municipalities who are working on plans
to
lower their consumption of
emitting fuels by a certain date like
2050 or something like that would this
be impacting folks in terms of their
ability to
uh state that they have that goal
no it would not prohibit any
municipality from stating a goal
it would not prohibit a municipality
from encouraging
certain investments but it would
prohibit a municipality from blocking
any kind of investment that they don't
particularly care for
following up i i understand
oh thank you i understand the the
impetus for
making sure that there aren't
unreasonable nimby type
ordinances and
going in at the municipal level to stop
all types of projects but i just want to
dig down a little deeper into the idea
of folks who already have a plan
if they already have a plan
on their goals in terms of
reaching a net zero emissions for
municipal buildings or town town
holdings and that kind of thing
wouldn't this bill
undo their ability to to do that only in
part
it if the fact that they encouraged
certain investments fine but it would
it would prohibit them from blocking any
kind of investment that doesn't happen
okay
further questions for representative
platt
representative callie pitts
and take my follow-up so
uh when you say the word representative
blocking do you mean by
particular zone local zoning ordinances
to stop a company from coming in for
instance any which way it could be a
zoning ordinance it could be a
it could be an ordinance from the select
board or whatever the system uh system
is it's a city uh mayor and oliver mayor
and council whatever entity municipal
entity it would stop them from blocking
anything uh that they don't particularly
care for for whatever reason
in my town there was a trash to energy
facility proposed i was on the planning
board at the time and 15 people might
show up normally at a planning board
hearing there was 1500 people showing up
accusing the planning board of taking
money under the table
all sorts of nasty things
and and there's a lot of emotion about
stuff like that but that really is uh
something that is
uh should be beyond the town and what we
wound up doing the the wheel of braider
fry removed that proposal and built one
in maine and we shipped our trash to
maine it was okay in maine but not in
our town and so that's a nimby sort of
reaction and it's sort of this is what's
prohibit that sort of stuff now if it's
big enough to go to site evaluation
committee you can argue with the site
okay
any further questions for representative
plett representative mick williams is
recognized thank you chairpost
representative platt i just want to
understand what this would mean for the
city of concord um which has enacted a
uh
we're basically going for
electric needs to be completely fossil
free by 2030 across the board both
municipal and private use in concord so
we've enacted this um statute for the
city of concord and what you're saying
here at least in section four
roman i a
uh you're saying that you can't enforce
the resolution so concord has gone above
and beyond to commit to this and now
we're as a state saying it's
unenforceable is that correct that's
correct
so just understand follow-up just so i
understand so that means that for other
cities and towns who have committed to a
certain type of energy
that would no longer be enforceable is
that your intention
i think the town can encourage forms of
energy
that just cannot block other forms of
thank you okay additional questions for
seeing none i thank you representative
plett for
whoops i think i was a last minute hand
i saw representative mann half second
late there
thank you mr chairman um would uh does
this
bill per allow a municipality
um prevent a municipality for
preventing
a gas line
being built through their territory yes
they still have the right to go to site
evaluation committee and argue but yes
it would stop a town or municipality
from blocking a pipeline thank you
representative partial is recognized for
a question
thank you sir returning to uh mc
representative williams earlier a
question about uh
section four one a
um
i'm reading the language and i'm hoping
ally my concern but um
uh
restricts or prohibits or has the effect
of restricting or prohibiting the types
of fuel sources of energy production
which may be used
delivered
converted or supplied to their customers
does that mean to say that uh community
aggregation when it makes commitment to
uh providing 20 green power would not be
able to make that commitment
as an example that's uh something i
haven't thought through thoroughly i
think that's broad it's not prohibiting
any particular source in their town
so so i'm not sure that that would
necessarily be restricted well thank you
so much i'm not sure from the language
but thank you for answering that
question nope no follow up
okay
any further questions for representative
plett
seeing none i thank you representative
plett for introducing this legislation
and now
i would like to
is it mitch grays from new hampshire
municipal association did i get that
right
[Music]
from the new hampshire municipal
association spell please
and thank you natch
and last name is spelled g-r-e-y-e-s
and nhma opposes this bill
um
we
in our first analysis we were interested
to see how this related to last year's
senate bill 86 which which passed
and was signed into law by the governor
um
we concluded that last year's bill
really looks the retail end at the
customer end so
a municipality could not for example
prevent a home builder from installing a
a propane
heating system or a propane
oven
the way we would would read this bill as
has
not only to do with kind of that retail
end but also sort of the delivery system
as well
and we're really concerned about the
unintended consequences here
um so there was a case a couple years
ago liberty utilities versus city of
concord
number 2015-0510
from 2017
where liberty utilities had to repair
the gas lines in downtown concord so
they dug up the road and that issue in
that case was okay who's going to pay to
repair the road concord had enacted a
fee schedule so that if you dug up the
road
you were required to
pay to restore the road and that was
debated it ended up going to the supreme
court and the supreme court said well
that's perfectly fair to charge the
utility company to repair the road
we're concerned about the unintended
consequence here because the language is
so broad
that if a municipality were to take any
action
that has the effect of restricting
the fuel source that could be used or
delivered
would that mean that that's overruling
the liberty utilities case in which case
the burden of repairing the road the
cost there would be borne by the
municipality by the taxpayers of that
municipality
rather than by the utility which caused
the
damage in the first place so we're
concerned about how broad this language
is
okay thank you
mr grace for your testimony on behalf of
the municipal association do we have
representative samsich
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
uh nate for taking my question
just just to be clear um what you were
just saying
uh is the concern of your organization
that
um
fuel choices that municipalities might
allow to happen or try to prevent from
happening
uh would
would end up being born by the taxpayers
instead of by the actual utility or
entity that does this is that is that
what
i don't quite understand the logic there
yes thank you for the question so
um in in looking at the language of the
bill and trying to square it away with
what is already the law due to last
year's sb 86
we were trying to figure out what the
difference is you know we can't
relitigate what happened last year you
already can't prevent someone from
installing you know their propane stove
um that's that's already the law so how
is this different
well if you have a utility that's
delivering something like natural gas
via their delivery system
and they need to go in and repair that
and part of that repair process is going
to require that they damage municipal
property so the municipal road for
example under which the gas line runs
one of the concerns has
been until 2017 when the supreme court
made a decision
who is responsible for repairing that
road
you know under the law the municipality
runs the operates the road it maintains
the road and there really isn't anything
in the statutes about anything that runs
under the road like the gas line
so who exactly is going to pay for that
repair and what standard is that repair
going to be
well
obviously the gas company could choose a
couple options right they could shut off
the gas line and say well we can't
deliver you gas anymore um or
they could go in and make that repair
um and if the municipality has said well
of course we want you to make the repair
um
but you're gonna have to pay for the
damage to our property
uh it's possible that this language is
so broad that the municipality wouldn't
be able to do that in which case it
overrules the supreme court's decision
and liberty utilities argument prevails
which would mean that liberty utilities
would say we have to go and repair our
gas line into your road and by the way
you have to figure out how to pay to
repave that because it's not our
responsibility
and that was what was at contention in
the liberty utilities case and we're
very concerned that based on the
language provided here that that would
be the result
follow-up
uh yeah thank you for that thank you mr
chairman thank you for that explanation
um would you be willing to suggest a
change that would make sure that doesn't
happen in this case
uh
i i'd certainly be happy to work with
the sponsor i don't have a suggested
okay thank you
next uh question representative callie
pitts
it's like i'm on a roll today what you
just described
if i'm interpreting it correctly is a
after the fact situation correct this
bill
if i'm interpreting it correctly and i
want you to tell me that
is a
pre
this says you can't put gas in my
i don't want your gas line you can't put
it in my town
it doesn't mean that if it's
pre-existing and it doesn't go into
those type of repair is what i see
if i don't want a coal plant in my town
i can say
this is preventing that
this is saying the town can't stop that
i don't believe it has
in my mind anything to do with the
situation you described which is a post
that they've already allowed and it's a
situation that arises all right can you
clarify that for me
yes thank you for the question um so
i understand that's the sponsor's intent
um but in in rereading this and
re-reading the liberty utilities case
that's what struck me as a concern um
not only kind of the pipeline the new
pipeline going through town
but
the legal questions surrounding the
existing pipeline and what happens if
something goes wrong and who's going to
pay for that
and that's why we were we were concerned
you need a follow-up yes
so you believe that this
bill
would
override and i'm not saying i'm for
against the bill but this bill would
override
that decision
even though that was a decision made on
something that was already existing
i i think that the language is broad
enough that it has the potential to
override that and
i i can't make the the call for the
okay thank you
additional questions
for mr grays
seeing none i thank you mr graves for
your testimony thank you
and i will now call on
john gage who
comes to the committee representing
himself and requests
to speak for four minutes mr gage the
mr gage is handing out some material for
the committee to
review
okay all the materials have at this
point been
circulated so
open the floor to mr gage and remind him
that you are here to speak on house bill
and you have four minutes
and don't forget to turn on the
microphone please
a little red button
down on the base down on the base
there you go
thank you very much chairman fos and
members of the
ste for hear my testimony today
do any of us know what climate policies
will be introduced by congress in the
next 20 years
of course not
i'm a member of the windham local energy
committee
and i pose this bill because it takes
local decision making away from
the first handout
that i wanted to call attention to
is this one
the executive summary of the fourth
national climate assessment this is from
the united states global change research
program
and it's required by law it's uh
basically what we know about climate
change and climate pollution according
to science
this is settled science there's
not a single organization in the world
that disagrees with this
the second
volume
is on the impacts and effects
of global warming from our climate
pollution most of which is carbon
emissions from fossil fuels
now
my town um was going to move toward
getting gas piped in a couple years ago
that was one of the reasons i joined the
committee
um
because
i work at the federal level to help them
put a price on carbon when that happens
local regions that have locked in on
fossil fuel infrastructure
to hopefully have cheap energy are going
to find themselves sitting on a bunch of
stranded costs because
their bet that fossil fuels were going
to remain cheap will have
proven not to be true
i don't think the state should make a
decision about whether
a town or city
can make that decision and make
bets accordingly what they want to do
the third handout is
starts with an economist statement
now this is the largest economist
statement supported by the most u.s
economist ever about anything
and it recommends
that the most cost-effective
and equitable way to reduce climate
pollution is to put a price on the
pollution where it enters the economy
rebate the money back to households
on an equal per capita basis each month
to protect purchasing power
and use border carbon adjustments
to protect us businesses from free
riding countries
this is the only way we can hold other
countries accountable for their climate
pollution and strongly motivate them to
in congress right now there's a bill
the reconciliation package
which looks like they're going to focus
on climate
a carbon price is one of the obvious
things for them to put into that
if you take the control of local
towns and cities
uh if you remove their ability to say we
don't want to invest in fossil fuel
energy in our in our local region
you're setting up developers to
build infrastructure that's going to be
um
46 countries are already pricing carbon
the eu now hit a 85 per ton price
um
and they're going to implement border
carbon adjustments which means they're
going to be charging us for our carbon
pollution when we import goods
into the eu marketplace 30 seconds
canada is also looking at doing the same
their price will be 135 dollars per ton
so
this is
settled science
um
economics
says putting a price on carbon and
rebated it is the most important first
step to address this pollution problem
congress is looking at doing it
so we should let our towns and
municipalities
anticipate that and make good decisions
um
and one of those would be to not
encourage the development of fossil fuel
infrastructure
thank you okay thank you for your
testimony appreciate it
i'm sure we have questions i know i have
a question uh my first question is is
your primary objection to this
legislation that it would remove local
control
yes just as the example of concord
was
talked about if a city makes a
commitment to get down to net zero by
2050 they should be allowed
the leeway to set the policies so that
they can achieve that goal
okay further questions for mr gage
representative mcgee is recognized thank
you mr chairman and thank you mr gage
for taking my question
i know we have a very active energy
committee in my town of hollis um and
they're really trying to look at every
way to save us money and also lower our
missions at the same time so they've
been
they've undertaken that planning uh
many maybe 20 years now we've been
working on it and you said you're also
on an energy committee in your town as
well right yes um so my question is
uh
it's my understanding and maybe you can
tell me because you're actually involved
on an energy committee personally that
the state encouraged towns to do this i
i thought it was the state that actually
asked towns to start looking at their
planning locally because we are a sort
of local control
type of state so do you have any
knowledge of that because i would like
to know more about
how that fits into this right
i'm sorry i don't know i i joined three
years ago so maybe this was interesting
you know before
i'm very new i i got into this because
of my concern about global warming and
climate pollution
i'm trying to help save my town and my
state and my country money because
if we lock in future fossil fuel
investments they're going to become
stranded costs so the oil and gas
industry would love us to continue
deploying infrastructure that uses their
products because that locks us into
their their
fuels but we know from global
momentum we're going to be paying other
countries for our climate pollution
soon if we don't put a price on it here
if we put a price on it here we can
recycle that money in our own economy
and protect family budgets so it just
seems
so simple to me that we need to price
carbon at the federal level with border
carbon adjustments and be the driver of
the global policy follow-up follow up so
okay so
when the chairman asked if local control
was your primary concern i think when i
was first looking at this bill i was
thinking of it in that regard but it
sounds like you're talking about
not just the environment but also the
economics
right so you're making an argument on
all three levels that you don't think
this is
desirable for new hampshire exactly
fundamentally from an economic
perspective
really
we're being pushed by industry to
continue using their product
or be manipulated by out of state
influences
and
we're an independent state we should be
proud
to do what we want at the local level
and at the state level
thank you
thank you representative harrington is
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question you've mentioned stranded cost
a number of times and i'm just trying to
figure this out since in new hampshire
now we only have merchant generators
so if anyone was to plan on building a
new fossil fuel plant since it would be
a merchant generator it would not be
utility
how would there ever be any stranded
costs associated with that other than to
the stockholders of the merchant
generator
i guess i look at it from a holistic
perspective of what the state has
invested in
so sb-82 i guess
means that we can't
prevent
people from installing gas for heating i
think that's a bad economic decision
because
developers will put in gas heating it'll
look like a cheap solution
um but then when congress puts a price
on carbon
um energy prices will start going up and
at some point those heating machines are
going to become obsolete before they've
they've
run the course of their life
and they're going to have to be replaced
so when i say stranded costs they're
they're
decisions throughout our whole economy
that will affect
renters
businesses
homeowners
we don't want to get locked into new
fossil fuel investments right now
because when there is a price on carbon
that comes from above
we're going to be getting stuck with
things stranded cost stranded assets
follow-up follow-up so just so i'm clear
on this then when you're talking about
stranded costs you're not talking about
the normal sense of the term where in
the case like for seabrook where there
was stranded costs the millions of
dollars the ratepayers had to pick up
you're talking about someone who makes a
decision on their own that i think it's
best for me to put in a propane heating
system in my new house
and then five years whatever years later
propane becomes very expensive so they
have to go to some other option the cost
you're talking about are the costs that
would be borne by the person who made
the decision to put the propane heating
system in their house
yeah at all different levels for example
i got into this when the ned pipeline
was trying to be deployed across
southern new hampshire
i didn't think a seven billion dollar
fossil fuel infrastructure project was a
good long-term
uh
investment in energy in our state i know
we weren't going to be paying it but it
is our economy the power of our economy
is driven by decisions that are made if
we make
the wrong long-term decisions we invest
billions of dollars in things that don't
work out
all of us lose
some people's directly but the economy
uh representative lewicky is recognized
for a question thank you mr chairman um
thank you mr gage
i
am wondering who determines what science
is settled what science is not and what
happens when the science turns out to be
not as subtle as it as it might have
been
well climate science is 200 years old
uh spent iranians in the
1800s calculated just through simple
physics
if we doubled co2 we'd get about
four degrees of global warming
this report is the best science we know
it's based on all of the available
evidence it's supported by every
scientific organization in the world
even exxon mobil had a scientific
organization in the 70s and 80s they
came to the same conclusions
unfortunately for human civilization
rather than promote the science and
and promote congress addressing this
pollution problem they chose a different
path
they funded misinformation and doubt
about the science to delay addressing
this pollution problem
okay i'm going to stop you right there
because we've strayed from the subject
of this legislation
uh we don't want to get into a
discussion here of climate i'll just say
that
there's not a single scientific
organization in the world
that says this is wrong
i i know of several so that's an
incorrect i would love
representative callie pitts do you have
a question yes please
um
i'm going to go back to this legislation
and i'm going to try to use
an example to
clarify what i think you're trying to
say
and i
i have to say that i can't agree with it
but i i
also all of medicine has told me that
sticking a candy bar in my mouth is not
the right thing i should do
and
they could put a tax on that candy bar
if i want that tax candy bar i'm going
to eat that candy bar
the government's or anybody else's
purview to tell me
don't
make that bad decision
and put that candy bar in your mouth in
other words do does a town
or a city
have the right to make its own
if need be bad decisions that i know
plenty of bad decisions were made on
cities and towns that's what we're doing
here would take you
in this bill
you're taking away or i believe you're
taking away the right
of somebody or a group of people to make
a bad decision should
should that happen in this society
wouldn't it
i the way that i look at it is
when the majority in the town decides
that they're going to commit to net zero
by 2050
and they need policies to do that
they might want to say we don't want any
more natural gas
infrastructure
installed
to promote this because it's
it's doesn't align with our goals so i
think the state should not be
deciding what towns can do
i preferences follow up even if in your
opinion
or
the opinion of some of the people in the
town
or even the majority of the people in
the town and the council rules it's a
bad decision
yes they have the right to make that bad
decision
and that i that i'm asking you do you
think that
stopping people from doing that
is
with a hammer is more effective than
education
um you know the fossil fuel industry has
way more money than anybody else to
educate the public about what they want
so
i'm not sure it's a matter of educating
the public
when there's a committee that's charged
with making energy decisions for a town
and they study the science they look at
what policy is happening around the
world and what's happening at the con at
the federal level
i think they ought to be able to make
decisions that they think are best for
the town and
whether they're right or not
local control is important to new
hampshire and i i think taking it away
is a mistake i'll bet anybody here
that there will be a price on carbon at
okay further questions for mr gage
representative partial
thank you chair and welcome
now let me if i understand this we're
talking about energy decisions which
also are economic decisions
and these
economic decisions they will be born by
the municipality should they choose
correctly or incorrectly
so
what we have here if i understand this
correctly and please correct me this is
a question
um if we seed the authority on making
these decisions to the state level or to
the
regulatory
to the suppliers of these uh
systems
then
we could be left holding the price tag
on their bad decision
is that the way i read this
that's exactly how i look at it it's in
the fossil fuels in just industries
interest to get us to continue using
their product
it's in the public's interest
to have a broader view of what's going
on around the world
to understand pollution
and to not be fooled into making
expensive decisions
that will hurt us in the end that was
enough thinking for me i don't have a
follow-up okay thank
you additional questions representative
samsich
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
gage for coming today um
in your opinion is
would this bill be an encumbrance and an
obstacle to communities who are now
considering community power as one of
their options locally uh to implement
and with this is a bill we passed just
last year
yes i think so i hadn't thought about
that until
it was brought up earlier but
you know when you start making
regulations about who can do what at a
high level you have all kinds of
unintended consequences i i don't think
the state should do that in this case
there's lots of reasons that local
regions might want to control
their power locally and i think we
should give them that option
follow-up
thank you
also um in light of the fact that
local decisions
end up paying getting paid by local
taxpayers
don't you believe that local
municipalities should have the priority
to make their own decisions instead of
dictating mandates from the state i
certainly do
that's a very important part i one of
the first
things i ever testified at was in pelham
gas company wanted to increase the
10-year
license for their compressor station in
pelham
and i testified and i said are you
considering the pollution that's going
to be released by continuing using this
in pelham and he said well that's not
written into the state's statute
we can't consider pollution
and i live two miles away from that
compressor station and and methane
is released all the time for those
things for various reasons and it causes
asthma which my daughter has and health
problems so you know
local control for energy because it's a
very polluting thing i think is very
important
thank you very much
further questions representative mcgee
this is your second
round of questions right
okay
and last right okay thank you i'll do my
best
okay so um to try to kind of wrap up
what has just been said
um
i think the the bill is striving to say
that
local control shouldn't be allowed to
sort of get in the way of decisions that
at this point local municipalities have
kind of taken responsibility for
and i guess
i've also heard you say um or someone
else said
that it's sort of a one-size-fits-all
approach to
you know nobody should be able to say
what
what is good and bad
right for their town
and i guess
what i see in looking at it in terms of
it being a law
is that there's a gap here because
those decisions are presently being made
at the local level and so they're
if you're no longer able to make those
decisions because that power was taken
away from you
then the ability to really discuss and
and uncover the solutions for your town
kind of get eliminated
um and so that's the that's just the
point i wanted to make is do you see
that's what i see here is do you see
that i agree that the town should be
able to make its own economic and
environmental decisions uh based on how
the citizens of that town choose to live
and how what they think is coming in the
future and how they can best prepare for
that we don't generally use one size
fits all so i just feel like it's kind
yeah that's all that's all i have to do
i have another question for you mr gage
if i live in a town
that's in the pathway of a highway say
route 101.
and the state wants to root route 101
through my town
should
my town have the ability to say no
to that state highway which could impede
orderly travel throughout the state and
provide great economic benefits to the
state
should my town be allowed to
to say no anyway
i don't think that's a very good analogy
chairman because
transportation goes from place to place
and there's obviously benefits in having
highways to travel long distances
whereas what we see with power
generation
it is shrinking it's becoming local
distributed
resources
which is going to push the decisions
down to local levels i mean we can have
an energy independent future
if all every each town produces its own
electricity and they ought to be able to
do that how they choose i think having
the state
you know kind of take the
the side of fossil fuel industries
because they don't want this
is damaging in a whole bunch of ways uh
to our state uh and particularly to
itan's independence and how they want to
okay so you didn't comment on the
concept
you just commented on the fact that
you think a town should be able to say
no for certain things but not for other
things i think transportation is a poor
analogy there are a lot of ways to
produce electricity there's only one
place to only one way to get cars from
here to there
okay thank you representative bernardi
is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman
mr gage as i read this bill it talks
about
all types of fuel sources so
fuel sources such as
wind or solar power and dispatching them
on
online
throughout a community on a microgrid or
whatever uh are equally covered compared
to
uh fossil fuel distribution lines
so
are you against the bill in its entirety
or just
for
fossil fuels
in its entirety uh i think towns should
have the the power to make decisions
about how they want to generate energy
in the future this is happening uh we
should encourage community power and
other things like that it builds
resilience
in the long term it's going to
produce much cheaper power
uh in town the the the trend is for
towns to be looking into how they want
to provide power to their citizens i i
think the state should not get in the
follow-up
no follow-up representative berezni is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
gage for taking my question uh would
this bill prevent a town from generating
its own electricity and can you explain
how
that community power would not be
possible if this passes thank you
i think you want henry earned in here
not me to talk about this
um
i it's a very high level summary of what
would happen but you're restricting the
town's ability
to
chart a course to meet their goals for
power generation in the future
the town should be able to decide if it
wants to burn trash to generate
electricity or not it should be able to
decide if it wants a five megabit
megawatt solar installation or not
it should be able to decide if it wants
natural gas piped in
uh to generate electricity or not
there's economic
you know
current economic
questions to answer that and long-term
economic questions
to determine those
those answers as well as environmental a
lot of people in new hampshire just
don't like pollution
and they are willing to pay more even
for power that's generated through
cleaner sources
a town should be able to make its
decision about how it wants its
electricity generated
follow-up
so if a town wants to install
a huge array of solar panels how would
this build prevent the town from doing
i think isn't that
basically the bill says
the town cannot
restrict any
fuel or electric sources so i guess
if like
if it's particularly about fuels i guess
maybe trash is a better example
clarification
yeah can you can you clarify that if if
the town wants to install if the
municipality wants to install a large
solar array how would this bill prevent
them from doing that
actually i don't know if it would or not
somebody else may be able to answer
it would not it would seem
it would not prevent them
but i was going to ask and i probably
should have asked the sponsor this bill
in no way prevents
and going to court and finding out if
what we've done is legitimate so if a
company wanted to put a cold powered
plant in the this
you know and the town didn't want it it
does not prevent the town from appealing
this
and i think i'm not a lawyer but i think
that's very important that the town will
still have rights i'm not saying i'm for
or against this bill but
we forget that sometimes that the town
okay thank you i think i mean speaking
as a local energy
committee person in town towns don't
have a lot of resources so if you're
talking about using the legal system to
address the right that's already
happened that's a wrong i
you know i think this is simply a state
control versus a local control issue
uh and the the local control for
economic reasons and environmental
okay
uh
before i take rep let representative
samsung ask a question i have another
question for you
what about individual
rights and individual control
let's say that
i have a house and i want to
install a
natural gas heating system
refuses to let a natural gas company
build a pipeline to serve the town
is the town then taking away
my control over my
energy choices and is that legitimate
well i think if the town has decided
to
not burn coal in that town and you
really want to burn coal there's other
towns
so you have certain rights but we also
have certain social responsibilities
and addressing pollution is an important
part of
the social contract that we all make if
if a town decides that the
the economics don't work out because
they think that there's going to be a
price on carbon and the local pollution
doesn't work out because they want clean
air and water and a stable climate then
they ought to be able to make a decision
um and if
if you don't like the decision um
you either live with it or go to another
town but we make decisions locally all
the time about how much we invest in our
schools
um
you know how roads are maintained
all of these are political decisions
that you decide whether you want to live
in the town or not
based on
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman uh and thank you
mr gage um
if
would you agree with me that if if i
lived in a scenic town in
somewhere in new hampshire nor north of
here
and that town because it's a touristy
town and it values the environmental
resources around it
decides uh for example through community
power or otherwise
that that
municipality is only gonna
generate generate or
buy
renewable energy
then they would be in violation of this
spill if it passed is that correct
that's how i read it i think they would
be really limited in what decisions the
town could could make yes thank you
okay
any uh additional questions for mr gage
seeing none i thank you mr gage for your
testimony in your literature this
afternoon
and having no
other pink cards on this uh
for people who want to testify i would
ask
representative pimentel to check the
blue sheet and representative plett to
representative pimentel there are three
names on the
sheet there is
one per one pro
and
two con
thank you and representative plett just
mr chairman there are three in support
47 opposed all from new hampshire
thank you
so with that i'm going to close the
public hearing on house bill 1148 we
will be
starting our next public hearing on
house bill
refresh your memory
when you read this if you notice anybody
on here
who's from leaderhouse leadership even
jason osborne i didn't but i'm scanning
high speed too
life absolutely that's trying to find
the right size right
anyway
you read the actual full report it
doesn't say anything that's a political
summary
look at the full report and make heads
hearing
that's what i did i did it just before
yep
is
yes
all right everyone i call to order the
public hearing on house bill
a bill authorizing a utility to petition
to be relieved of their carrier of last
resort obligations and i introduce the
bill's prime sponsor representative
michael harrington
thank you mr chairman
let me start out by saying there's one
question that needs to be resolved on
this bill that's more administrative
than anything else and
what it does is it
talks about i'll get into the details
for the second but it mentions the
department of energy in multiple
positions here i'm not positive yet as
to whether it should be the puc or the
department of energy the problem is
neither group really has a telephone
group in it at all so it's part of what
looking at what we're looking at with
the puc and the doe right now we'll come
up with the decision where best goes
so that's just so before that question
gets asked so it's uh
um
maybe someone from doe could comment on
that
the reason for this is this is a
leftover thing from when we had
regulated telephone services one of the
last things left it obviously cost money
for the the um incumbent utility which
is
most places is consolidated but there
are others in the state
and they have to provide this where
simply it no longer exists this uh need
to do this this is going back 20 30
years ago where people didn't have cell
phone service they didn't have cable
options your voip voice over ip
uh there's so many different competitors
on there i mean every time you turn on
tv there's a uh a different uh
cell phone company coming up uh telling
you they're gonna sell the service
you've got broadband you've got all
these other things and this just simply
says if they find that it's not there
and they give the conditions there i'm
not going to read all the details
everyone can read the bill themselves
that then they can make a decision that
they no longer have to be this provider
of last resort and
because the decision would be that they
there's certainly ample things out there
and
people might say well what's the benefit
of this well
the benefit of this is that
every time we put a burden on the
incumbent utility that accomplishes
virtually nothing as far as giving
better service
it there's a cost involved in that and
if the cost involved that means it's
like they're less competitive and less
competitive means everyone's going to
pay a little bit more money in the long
run we want to have a vibrant uh
competitive uh
um system here with the understanding
that the incumbent utilities uh you know
for the most part only central offices
and even though you think all your cell
phones uh conversations don't go through
there they do so we want to make sure
that they stay around and are healthy
and
it's pretty much as simple as that is
the if you want i'm going to have a
couple of people from the telephone
companies uh speak on if you have more
specifics uh but that's all it does is
this is something that's was needed 25
or 30 years ago it simply isn't needed
anymore due to competition and
widespread use of other forms of
um
telephone service uh it kind of almost
dates back to the old
pre-verizon uh bell days so with that
i'll take any questions
thank you representative harrington for
introducing this bill
and before you
[Music]
get too far i'll just remind you you
need to fill out a pink card for the
record okay right okay thank you
i do have one quick question you
mentioned in your testimony that the
benefit from this bill would be to
relieve incumbent utilities
of certain burdensome costs you have any
idea
how much money we're talking about i
would prefer that the actual companies
speak on that because i don't have i
don't have exactly figure okay thank you
representative samsit has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
representative harrington taking my
question
i just want to clarify first of all
the
the requirement for being relieved of
this burden
is that
there is at least one other
wire based
network available
or or is it or and
there is also a wireless
service available
i'm suspecting that in many places there
is just one wire uh i mean
non-mobile phone network available and i
guess those are the people who are
uh kind of stranded in places where
they put wires in there long time ago
and they have them
so are you suggesting that
there are com competitors to uh
uh non non-mobile carriers that are
available to these people if if
the current
service provider stops serving no what
i'm suggesting is that those criteria
have to be met so if you had a situation
where there wasn't at least one wire
facilities based voice network and a
one or more mobile
commit let me split that out again
telecommunications service providers
that they couldn't they couldn't be
relieved of their burden or whatever you
want to call it their obligation to
serve the wire customer that's why the
criteria there it doesn't say you the
incumbent utility does away with this
class of customers altogether it just
says in the overwhelming majority of the
state it it's uh not it's does it's not
needed but in those places where it is
needed it would stay that's why this
criteria has to be met before it can be
relieved of that
follow-up follow-up
okay i understand that that makes sense
and uh however you also say
there has to be a wire line
network person available that covers at
least 95 percent of the households
in other words
there could be five percent of the
households who are not covered by them
or by three percent people who would not
be covered by a mobile phone
aren't those exactly the kind of people
that were at the end of the line
uh were
if they're i mean i realize they're just
a small percentage of of the town but
nonetheless
uh you know we're trying to make sure
that everyone has equal access to phone
yeah i i
think this criteria and like i said this
these exact numbers would derive from
the utilities because they'd obviously
done more analysis and know more about
it than i do but i think this is a
balancing thing we have to look at and
say you just can't shut it off
completely but when you read this this
level then you're probably going to be
okay i mean there's some i mean we've
had
a series of
bizarre telephone rules in new hampshire
over the years
maybe well jackie's probably around to
remember some of these but
but she remembers the only person
she remembers when god was a little boy
so
that's right and anyways there was
actually one there was actually a rule
that came up because i testified when i
was a commissioner on it and it said
that if somebody called up the puc to
complain about their telephone service
and they had caller id the puc was not
allowed to help them with that at all if
they called back the next day and said
i've gotten rid of uh caller id the puc
amanda would say up what do you want i
can help you so there's always there's
always little quirks that we've been
trying to work out with that
deregulation because it wasn't quite the
same as with electricity where it was
just saying you know get rid of your
power plants because it was more of a
transition i just think this is another
one of the steps in the transition okay
thank you representative plett is
recognized for a question yes thank you
i was confused at first because it says
a utility doesn't see a telephone
utility
and so uh
and i read the body and i saw that it
was indeed telephone utilities but it
crossed my mind that electric utilities
still have provider of last resort even
though they don't own anything anymore
so could this be broadened to cover the
remove the
provider of last report for electric
utilities or gas utilities
you're not the only one who raised that
concern with me uh so uh in fact i got
some very excited people from the
electric utilities calling
that
i have no problem with adding the
incumbent telephone utility if it
clarifies it to make so there's no
confusion because it's not supposed to
apply to uh electric utilities it's just
telephone
okay uh representative pimentel is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative harrington
um
i'm curious about
what happens it looks like
the incumbent utility would petition the
department of energy and
if
what would the department of energy do
say
yes or no
and then if if they say yes
you you're no longer the resort the last
resort
carrier
would that mean the other utility that
is hooked up
then with 95 percent would become the
last resort or there be no last resort
utility my understanding would be no
last resort because of certain other
words the idea that the service was
sufficient enough so that you would let
competition decide what service they got
whether it be i mean you can get
typically you could get satellite you
can get voip
you can get
wireless you can get landline all those
follow up
thank you mr chairman
uh so just for clarity you're saying
that because there are
at least two
land lines and
cell service then there is no need for
um
a utility of last
resort correct if the criteria listed
here were met
then there would there would be no
utility thank you
okay thank you uh
representative callie pitts you have a
question
microphone on please
besides being a
old fossil
and having a landline i worked for the
companies i know that
i would like to know
it's having a landline what would happen
should the current
telephone company decide
i'm not providing landline service
anymore
can they just shut it off like that
without
notice and having somebody to cover
that landline service
quite honest i don't know what the law
is on that i would assume that there's
some process involved in before they can
disconnect but i would refer to one of
the representatives from the utilities
because i'm sure they know that better
than i do
follow-up i would save it for the
utilities so i would hope they would
address it so i don't have to ask the
question what would happen
you used to have to
leave 9-1-1 available
so you could come in and plug in a phone
and call 9-1-1 no problem
what would happen to
customers who have
any service now
not being able if a company should cease
to exist
have nine one one service
and i would hope
i i i don't know if you know that answer
but i would hope that the companies
would address that i'll defer to them on
that one thank you
representative partial is recognized for
a question
thank you chair thank you representative
farrington
if i'm reading this it says at least one
wireless facilities based uh voice
network
and and one or more mobile telecom
communications service
uh
at 95 and 97 percent of coverage in the
municipality respectfully
that seems like a fairly
high bar to be able to even consider
applying to ask to be relieved of the
carrier of last resort
again not trying to not answer your
question but the the actual numbers came
from the utility so i'm assuming they
put research into getting those so you
could hold that question until they
speak they would give you a better
answer than i can i sure will thank you
so much
representative samsich
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
harrington uh just because of the
comments we just i just heard
uh it seems to me
that even if these requirements are
there that there is another
uh wire-based company
like represent kelly pitts was saying
let's say let's say a landline
there is another company would provide
landline
and another mobile company
they're not obligated to take her as a
customer
so if the company is relieved of its
duty to provide her that landline
there's no
and can i follow up
and and what what uh what is the what do
you understand what is the level of
proof that a company would have to
provide to the department of energy uh
before they can do this what what what
is the proof of this i understand uh we
have this criterion with alternatives
here but
what does that look like as far as if
they go and say this is why we want this
and here we can prove that is there some
vehicle of proof i'm assuming they'll
have to use some type of maps or
something that shows cell coverage area
as well as where the wire-based
facilities go but again the utility
should be able to give you more
information on that but obviously it's
not just calling up and saying yeah we
met the criteria thanks they're going to
have to give some facts to back it up
does anyone else
have a question for
uh representative harrington
before i go back to representative kelly
pitts i guess representative mcgee has a
question yes thank you mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question
representative harrington
i'm just looking in the methodology
under the fiscal note and it mentions
that the department's unaware of
arrangements made by the state county or
local governments for telephone service
the cost of that service or the cost of
changing that service
should a telephone utility cease to
provide service or fail to extend
service to a customer
um and i guess my question is
what was the
you mentioned that this is kind of an
antiquated
relief from
being the carrier of last resort service
so
so the
my understanding is that oftentimes
what we're doing by having something
that's uniform like a carrier of last
resort status is to say that you're
guaranteeing that people will be able to
get service through them even though it
may be expensive to bring the service to
them
is that part of the factor in this in
wanting to
take it away
yeah well you've got to go back in time
a little bit the whole concept of this
customer like this was set back when we
had franchised areas back under you know
new england bell
excuse me and
the obligation there was that the
telephone company had to provide service
out to somebody and let's say there was
you lived at the you know three quarters
of a mile down a dirt road you were the
only house out there well they would
have to run the thing out and that cost
would just be put into the rates that
everybody paid it wouldn't be a
significant uh increase to the to the
singular person there that was the whole
idea of the way the the pre-regulation
of
pre-deregulation worked for telephone so
this was by saying that now we don't
need those anymore because we've got so
much competition and especially with
wireless and satellite and everything
else has come in there you know things
that
excuse me
couldn't be even envisioned 20 or 30
years ago when it was thought that the
only way you could have telephone
service was you know one company running
wires because that was the only one that
made sense so this is kind of what the
change is on that so just a follow-up
same line of questioning
and the only other thought that i had
was are there areas in new hampshire
where
um
where those levels of competition don't
actually affect people's ability to get
phone service i know we have all those
available to us but are there areas that
are dead zones for that that
i would assume they're uh
excuse me i would assume there are some
and that's that's why the criteria has
been placed in here and they would have
to show that if they wanted to get
relieved of the being the supplier of
last resort in that particular area
they'd have to show that these criteria
were met before they could do that but
again the the people from the utilities
could probably give you a little bit
better okay thank you
representative harrington uh i have a
quick question
the effective date of this legislation
is 60 days after its passage but it
apparently incurs some costs according
to the fiscal note
the department estimates the cost of
employing consultants will range from
between 50 to one hundred thousand
dollars
does that mean that the effective date
should be
uh july 1st of 2023 after the
next budget is prepared i'm not sure the
cost issue here there's been a lot of
controversy on that as far as exactly
who's going to have to do what
and if the
i think if the utilities and i'm going
to let them speak to this because they
know better of what they're going to do
but my what i would envision is they're
going to do the work and they're going
to come up with the the maps that are
public records that can show where cell
coverage is and where cable companies go
and where landline goes and everything
else and they're going to present a case
and bring that to the doe
assuming it's doe and not puc i don't
think they're going to i don't see that
they would have to go outside and hire a
special consultant this is this is not
going to be rocket science it's going to
be
looking at
you know houses on maps and seeing what
kind of coverage they have so i think
that might be a little bit high but
we do have i think
the the doe still here maybe they could
comment on that specifically okay thank
you
representative callie pitts you have
another question
question for
representative harrington
with your expertise representative
harrington and what this committee did
a few years ago where we ceded authority
over the telephone companies we kind of
cut them loose
do you believe
that this type of legislation is real
and i mean that it has to be enacted or
that right now it would have no effect
because my understanding was that we
were out of the telephone business as
far as the puc was concerned and
i don't know where the doe
would pick it up because it's gone they
didn't move it over because it's gone
so i
i'm wondering if this is just a
housekeeping measure not a real one no i
think it's a little bit more the
housekeeping measure because there's
cost involved in it for the incumbent
utility so it would be something that
could be resolved so that they would say
as far as the
um
the utility the telephone expertise yes
i think uh
that kind of went away in the puc and
that's why i say it's i'm gonna have to
talk to both puc and the doe on this as
to where it would be more appropriate to
file it it was the doe seemed to be
because it was more administrative but
then again the department of energy
doesn't say anything about telephones in
their description either but uh i don't
think the puc has anything left on that
either so just that's that's something
that needs to be worked out it's a valid
point
quick follow-up quick follow-up as i
thought we ceded all authority
there's still a little left
okay thank you i i think we should move
on because we have two representatives
from uh telephone utilities here and
we'll probably get a lot more clarity on
some of these questions if we bring them
to the stand but before we do that i'd
like to bring the department of energy's
griffin roberge to the stand to give us
his take on this legislation
thank you chairman vos members of the
committee for the record griffin roberge
from the new hampshire department of
energy i'm here to testify give neutral
testimony on house bill 1328
i know there were some questions
regarding
the fiscal note so i'll start at the top
work my way down
the bill as representative harrington
indicated permits an incumbent telephone
utility to petition doe to relieve it of
any carrier of last resort obligations
in one or more municipalities if certain
conditions are met um
the first one being there is at least
one other wireline voice provider that
provides service to at least 95 percent
of households in the municipality or
and one or more mobile providers that
offer aggregate services to at least 97
percent of the households in the
municipality
second one is there is another provider
or providers that have received state
federal or municipal funding to serve
the entire municipality
there was some question as to what
criteria would be established per the
bill lines
13-14
doe is
allowed to adopt rules to enforce this
section
regarding the fiscal note
doe is assuming that it would either
have the option of
adopting rules
that depend on the utility to certify
compliance with the bill's criteria in
which case the department just collects
information that the telephone utility
provides and we say yep meets the
criteria good to go or
we're adopting
rules that require doe to analyze the
data that the telephone utility provides
to confirm that it meets the criteria of
the of the bill so that's where we
become a question as to what degree of
involvement the part is taking in this
process and
overlooking the criteria
so that's where the department
anticipated that would cost roughly 50
to 100 000
for each consultant and we're
anticipating two consultants one for
wire one for non-wireless um and that
would likely be paid through general
assessment and spread amongst the
utilities customers
just for background as has been
mentioned the telecom industry
is
vastly deregulated in the state um
competition in this industry is meant to
provide alternatives obviously lower
costs for consumers
in this context though
the incumbent carriers are those former
telephone utilities that had designated
franchise areas
and these incumbent carriers have a
carrier of last resort obligation i mean
they have to provide at least a basic
level of service to all customers in a
given area
the department in reviewing the bill did
want to express some observations that
while the telecom industry com uh while
the telecom industry competition is
quite robust in some parts of the state
such as your your cities your large
towns that have a greater population and
demand can be higher many rural parts of
the state do not have a higher level of
competition due to a lesser demand less
population
those rural areas are also less likely
they have
certain
aspects of wireless
service coverage rural households would
therefore
not always but likely rely on their
carrier of last resort for basic
telephone service
um obviously the bill permits a carrier
of last resort to withdraw from its
obligation to serve a municipality if at
least 95 are served by a wire provider
and 97 by a wireless voice provider
however the bill doesn't establish any
other criteria regarding service
availability or any requirement to serve
all customers in a given area so this
could lead to some percentage of
households being unable to access
telephone service at times when they
might need it for
emergency services medical needs that
type of thing
similar concerns extend to the second
element of criteria on lines 11 and 12.
a provider or multiple providers may
have received
some level of government funding
to serve an entire municipality but the
bill does not state the type of service
that's provided whether it's voice
service or broadband or any guarantee
that such service continues to be
provided on what the terms and
conditions are
i think the most important criteria the
observation that the department want to
know is that the criteria for permitting
an incumbent telephone company to drop
service in the town only focuses on the
competitive landscape
at a specific point in time so if you
have competition now
it can't speak for what it might be in
the future it doesn't have any
consideration as to what change may
occur after the incumbent has
discontinued service so in theory it is
conceivable that
similar business considerations
regarding lesser demand would result in
competitors leaving a municipality or
municipalities and that could occur
without any doe review or approval um it
just there's a i guess
some potential unintended consequences
in which residences in your rural areas
your small towns might lose access
including service for
necessary communica communication
services such as like i said uh
contacting a doctor or emergency
services um with that i apologize i
rambled on but that concludes the
department's testimony
thank you mr roberge any questions
representative flett has a question
yes i see the language of the bill
in line four
relatives carrier of last resort
obligations in one or more
municipalities correct so that this is
not a blanket relief you might be
relieved in manchester but have to keep
okay
and what i think
it i guess that's something that might
need a little bit more specificity there
um again i think the department is
concerned that
there is language in here that would
allow an incumbent with their carry of
last resort obligation to opt out of
this obligation in which case they just
have to prove that 95
97 of households are served again that's
it might be a small amount but it's more
or less saying that there are some
households that
can kind of be left alone per se
thank you mr chairman uh
thank you for coming
and
hearing our questions um
on the the fiscal note the very bottom
it says that um and we're talking about
these department estimated costs for
consultants between 50 and 100 000
it reads there uh those costs would be
directly assessed to the petitioning
utility
which may then attempt to recover the
cost from its customers
so if i get this right i mean the whole
idea was initially in the good old days
to provide everybody phone service even
if they did live far away from
a bigger area
so those installations were made those
polls were put in place
and when they were those costs were paid
for by the all the customers together
to make sure that everybody got service
now what this bill says is now in order
for somebody to be relieved of this cost
because the department now has costs
those costs now will go back to the same
customers to be paid for again
it seems to me
i don't know how much cost can be
involved here because the initial
installation probably was the most
costly part
maintaining those lines over many years
couldn't have been that expensive
so once they're in place
taking them out is like creating dead
capital where there was something before
uh don't you agree that maybe uh
financially this doesn't seem like it
makes sense well i
thank you for the question
representative i can't speak to
i can't speak to what the cost would be
for removing
telephone infrastructure that's been
there for years but at least just you
know pertinent to the bill just the cost
of the consultants for rule making would
be paid for by doe's general assessment
which would be levied on the telephone
utility petition
petitioning the department and they
would likely spread those costs amongst
the rest of their customers so you know
it being what it is you know yeah that's
i guess the way i would answer this just
the cost of the consultants are spread
amongst the telephone's utility
customers okay thank you
representative pementel
uh yeah thank you
uh
i have a i i don't know like a nightmare
scenario looking at this whole thing
and the nightmare scenario is that
in places that actually meet the
criteria
they would all of a sudden find
themselves with
no carrier of last resort
and then
um
the powers that be could
discontinue
all wired service to that area
and bring on
what is being touted as the new thing
5g
and and that would become the only
choice
is that
an unreasonable scenario
i think that's in part what the
department is expressing concerned with
is that when you have a
incumbent utility let's just envision
that this whole process set up goes
through and everything like that um an
incumbent utility petitions the
department meets the criteria is
relieved of that
carrier of last resort obligation
that that
obligation does not then carry on to
you know the other wire provider or
wireless provider in that area
and so
if again it's only capturing the
criteria only captures at one moment in
time you know there could be people who
move in out of an area and that type of
thing so it's conceivable that
the wire or wireless provider that's
there after the incumbent utility leaves
takes into account business
considerations and decides there's
lesser demand and competitors might move
to and you know leave the municipality
or take their business elsewhere in
which case again that carrier of last
resort obligation is no longer there so
there might be the potential not saying
it will happen the potential
of
of some people in rural areas you know
having difficulty accessing
communication services for emergency
services
thank you
okay further questions for
uh representative lewicky
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
roberge um i'm seeing as i see this goes
by municipalities and maybe you're the
wrong person but
it's very conceivable that people in one
part of a municipality might have good
cellular service and a significant
number of them would drop their uh
landline
bringing that number down to some small
percentage where
people within the same municipality
might not have cellular service and
might
essentially be cut loose just because of
meeting the percentage requirements can
you speak to that please i mean i guess
let me there is a uh a thing on the puc
website um right now that lists out all
the utilities by city and town
predominantly consolidated
communications fills a significant
majority of those areas but in some
municipalities you'll see some crossover
tds telecom might be involved in some
parts of municipality consolidate as
well
in regards to your question
give me some rope and feel free to hit
i got sidetracked what was your question
i'm sorry representative um
in some municipalities there might be
good cellular service in one part of the
municipality and then in a more rural
part of that same municipality there
might be
no wireless service and if substantial
numbers of people within the good
service part of town decide to drop
their uh landlines because they've got
the wireless service that then could
leave people in the same part of town
potentially in the dark
yeah i'm sorry and thank you for
repeating the question i apologize i
didn't grab it the first time but again
that i guess circles back to the
department's concern is it's only
grabbing a moment in time as to where as
to what households have in the
marketplace so you know okay at this
point you might have 97 percent um who
have a wireless provider but then
um 95 percent whoever wired provider
what have you but it could change over
time
and if people leave or anything like
that or people move out or that type of
thing
there's no mechanism for the doe
to issue any review or approval of that
so some people again could be left in a
gap and not have any access to
telecommunications services that's i
okay representative oxenoum has a
question
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr roberts for taking my
question and thank you representative
plett for bringing up cornish
i had an inquiry just yesterday from a
constituent in cornish who's very
concerned about the area where he lives
where there is no cell phone coverage
and you know we we think about you know
rural distances there's also problems
with mountains
there there are many problems here in in
the 20th century one one of the great uh
social progressive measures was rural
electrification we made sure everybody
had access to telecommunications in the
21st century
this is
high-speed internet is an absolute
essential and towns will get left behind
businesses will leave if they don't have
high-speed reliable communications i'm
very concerned that this 95 and 97
percent
is going to leave
it it's walking away from that guarantee
at a time when we need to be stepping up
and saying yes universal access for
every
resident every business in new hampshire
is a social good a social necessity
and
this this seems to be opening the door
to walking away from that shared
commitment that we've had in this
country for for a hundred years
do you share that concern i i i i
wouldn't i guess just from the
department's perspective obviously we
just want to i think we just want to
ensure that
people are not necessarily
unintentionally left out
of important telephone service
specifically in times of emergency when
they might need to contact a doctor
9-1-1 or something like that
i think that's just the concern of the
department we just want to raise that
unintended consequence during the
committee meeting and if people want to
modify the language or you know make
some clarifications more than willing to
be a party in those discussions but at
least just temporarily as the bill is
written we just raised concern about
those in small communities in rural
areas of the state
thank you
uh representative platt has a question
back in the good old days with uh
marbell
uh its various names um there was 100
availability availability almost 100
service
uh and so the the utilities could afford
to provide
provider of last
resort but isn't a different situation
today when very few people except
fossils like me still have a landline
and so that th
they're going broke essentially so how
can you continue to demand provider of
last resort under those conditions
thank you for the question
representative um you know it's just
in obviously in rural parts of the state
as has been mentioned there are those
dead zones where people don't have
access to phone service or anything like
that um
and some of those individuals still rely
on landline services to some degree
um if you know we
and i certainly understand um there
being robust competition in the uh
telecom industry obviously that's one of
the re that's a factor as to why it was
deregulated but
again it just circles back to the
department having concern about people
not having an ability to have
telecommunication services if it's left
if it's left open to uh a carrier of
last resort dropping their obligation
you have other telecom industries coming
in there and they make they don't have
an obligation anymore they make they
make decisions based on you know what's
best for the company and that type of
thing
i hope that answers your question
all right thank you mr roberge i think
we want to move on here because we've
got two representatives from telephone
companies and i think they have a lot of
good information to provide to us so i'd
like to
call now on teresa rosenberger who's
representing the new hampshire telephone
association
hello ms rosenberger nice to see you
again nice to see you all and i'm here
representing the new hampshire telephone
association which is all the landline
phone companies
i would be happy for sarah davis to come
with me or she can speak separately she
represents consolidated so your choice
would you like sarah with me or you want
me to go first and then she can bet
clean up
um
why don't you go first perfect
so that we can ask questions and then
perfect it'll be easier i think all
right
i'm theresa rosenberger i work for
bernstein shure a law firm i'm here
today representing the new hampshire
telephone association this is all the
landline telephone companies in the
state
that is as i've mentioned consolidated
it's granite state telephone it's tds
it's dunbarton telecom and it's bretton
woods now to answer somebody's question
it used to also be dixiel telephone
dixville telephone and i think you guys
are some of you who've been around a
while like my friend represent pitt
remembers me testifying years ago that
we needed to figure out how to allow
dixville telephone to go out of business
because they had a total of five
customers
and when the balsams was
was functioning and the balsams itself
must have had at least
five hundred to a thousand lines but
when the boston's closed
dixville telephone literally had
two tillotsons and two employees who
were five customers
now as much as there were five customers
um
dixiel telephone could not go out of
business without the approval of the new
hampshire puc
and we had to have the fcc approval as
well
that law with and deregulation had
passed so that is still the case
even if dunbarton telephone which is a
very defined area
wants to go
close up and no longer provide lean line
they have to have permission from the
state in um and federal government and
i'm sorry to have my back for you too
it's a little it's a little it's hard to
do anyway
so let me just give you a little bit of
an overview which representative
harrington did a great job of doing
back in
1934 when we had the original
communications act there was a duty to
serve all in your territory
and this is back in the old days when
literally each telephone company was
given a territory it was a monopoly
so they had a territory and in that
territory they had to serve
and it didn't really make any difference
where you were you had to serve them
with landline
then in 1996 they passed the telecom act
of 96 and that act was really geared
towards competition
i will say to you and as many of you
know i did uh was associated with
fairpoint for a while
there is absolutely no question in 25
years there is tremendous competition
and it's cable it's void it
it's satellite it's wireless etc the
telecom act of 96 has really actually
succeeded
uh they did say though
that if you were going to be relieved of
your carry of last resort obligation it
had to be approved by the state and it
had to gain the support of the local
commission the local puc
so
today those states that have limited or
gotten rid of their carry of last resort
obligations
had to have
approval by the the commission or or the
state
um
so this legislation is really enabling a
legislation from my point of view
there are now um and i have to honestly
say i haven't checked today but
there are uh 38 states that have limited
limited carry of last resorts
obligations the nine states that have
none
three states didn't answer a survey so
i'm not really quite sure what's going
on in those three states
but
the bottom line is as the industry has
changed people as just as representative
harrington said
have said wait a minute we got to change
with it why if take example
my client granite state telephone and
then there and where
where has
a hundred percent competition
and and not just on the
cable side but also on the wireless side
now does the town of washington have a
hundred percent no because washington's
a little more rural there's been no
question over the years washington is
desperately wanted wireless
it's kind of there not really so would
granite state
come in and make an application to the
department of energy or the puc
whichever one we want to call it um for
being relieved of the carry of last
resort in washington no
they can't meet the criteria they
wouldn't do it you can the way this bill
is written do
do
town by town in may they passed um they
basically limited their cola regulations
in 2016. now i don't like to think
frankly that we're ever behind maine but
we're behind me
and so when they did it they actually
specified certain towns like you can do
portland you can you can do augusta so
and this one it's really up to the
company to say where do i not where do i
have 95
competition on the land line or the
wired side and we're going to have 97
percent competition on the wireless side
and then move forward now i will tell
you some of my clients that are members
of the association aren't going to
exercise this for one reason or another
it's a business decision whether you
exercise it so they may they may well
not
so anyway
i see this is enabling i see this is
totally
having
the new hampshire department of energy
puc in control
absolutely if anybody decides to give up
landline they got to go to the ps the
state and the fcc
um i see this is actually there was a
report i read a while back that said
every state on a regular basis should
actually do an analysis of the carry of
last resort resort to see if we're
keeping up with where things are now
where the industry is and all the
changes to my knowledge we have not done
it so this is the first attempt to say
hey let's move forward let's become
current and let's really um
let's really allow these companies
opportunities when there's full
competition
to answer i think i answered your
somebody's question
about the um the
can you go out of business
the other thing that's happened just so
you know back in 2012
we passed deregulation of the
telephone
utilities and that was again of the
landlines because we were heavily
regulated i will say
and i think some of you heard me say
when i was at fairpoint and running that
company i came in here at one point and
said i feel like i've got shackles
because
and i think you might have been on the
commission then but we had
our regulations were unbelievable we
couldn't compete we had a labor union we
had service quality and it was just it
was unbelievable
deregulation in new hampshire passed in
2012 and i am proud to say
all of the landline companies i think
today are doing far better their their
prices are better they're quite
everything everything's working but
having said that
consolidated who's back there
if they want to go into granite state
telephone territory they can
comcast has always been
able to go in chart has been able to go
in wireless has been able to go in but
the old mob bells have not been able to
go into the other mobile territory
they can now you also now as you all
know municipalities are competing that's
why the language is in here about the
municipalities i mean you've got some
municipalities that are are right now
building for unserved and they're
looking to build completely built for
served and unserved so i look at this as
modernization and bringing us up to
where we should be
the other things i'd say in here is the
section about rules
so a lot of the questions that were
asked of griffin and a lot of the
questions can be dealt with
in rules i also the assessments
right now and i'm sure sarah davis will
say more about this than i will but
right now all the telephone companies
are paying assessments to the puc or
department of energy
i'm not sure we actually have a person
over there that does telecom but we
still pay
so
if doe needs a consultant it comes out
of those assessments we pay it will not
come out of the general fund it comes
out of those assessments
i think i talked about town by town so
we can go town by town so
maybe you know there are towns that we
will certainly i think many of these
folks will not look at including
including um consolidated i do have the
site if anybody wants it on the
fcc and the federal communications
act of 96 and
people not being able to go out of
business without commission
i can't remember if i missed anything
but i'm here to answer questions oh i
knew you'd ask a question but he's got
to recognize you first
thank you and before i do
i just heard you say something that i
want to clarify make sure i understood
correctly did you say
that the puc is still assessing
telephone companies even though they
have no regulatory authority over them i
did say that do you know approximately i
did i did say that yes you know
approximately how much money is involved
i can get you the numbers
i will get i mean the assessments have
gone down there's no question a number
of years ago we kind of said wait a
minute you don't have anybody so the
assessment's going down but we're still
being assessed and i think if i'm
correct miss davis is shaking her head
when you say the assessments have gone
down no no no what no no wait wait wait
wait wait
wait wait that what i was going to say
to clarify is that it percentage-wise it
went down and then when the department
of energy was created they all of a
sudden went back up and that was to
cover the cost of the department of
energy so
way back when we got deregulation and
there was no staff the percentage of
what we paid was going down now for they
claim it's going down after this year
after we get the department of energy
but no we pay all of the companies pay
okay i'll ask you this question i asked
representative harrington and he he
deferred it to you oh dear he described
one of the benefits of this legislation
as really relieving the incumbent
incumbent utilities
of costs
uh
do you know approximately how much those
costs would be i'll let mrs davis um
answer that because i did not i did not
survey but i'm happy to do so all the uh
all the other all the other companies
okay i'm sure representative callie
pitts has a question
being a dinosaur and still having i'm
with you i'm with you remember having a
landline yeah and
and the companies you know we heard a a
presentation on 5g that said don't hold
that in your head use your landline so
now
i want to know and i asked before
hopefully that i wouldn't have to ask
the question was the 9-1-1 situation
when you when you aban when you leave an
area you abandon the area
and
say three percent because you only have
to have 97 percent served so three
percent of the people are without
service
is there still what we call left in
9-1-1 that people can get 9-1-1
and do you perceive
this particular
movement
cell phones i couldn't afford a thousand
dollar cell phone which is what's out
there now
is that a movement that we're going to
get away from land lines and just go to
wireless well i think two questions okay
i think and i i hopefully you'll ask ms
davis the same question i think in this
we're not asking you to get rid of
landline service and where their service
now their service we're just getting
asking to get rid of the carry of last
resort uh and that means you have to you
have to serve anybody anywhere and it
really impacts basic service now when
when
when there was deregulation back in 12 a
lot of the standards left but the one
thing the company consolidated at that
point fear point still had to do was
offer basic service
and we had to offer that as i recall and
sarah helped me because sarah sarah was
in regulatory back then too as i recall
we had a cap on how much that cost could
go up for five for four years i think
and then after that the cap went went
off
now
everybody still is offering basic
service but there's no cap and that
doesn't mean if like me i have basic
service i have
two landlines and i have wireless but
i've got a landline on my alarm system
now guess what
i'm using basic service because i don't
use that so why should i pay 40 or 50
dollars a month
um so it just because you're eliminating
the carry of last resort doesn't mean
you're eliminating service and you
doesn't mean you're eliminating the
availability of service even now you've
got in some depending on the company and
in some parts of the state somebody
who's down a five mile dirt road
and the company has an obligation to go
so far and then that person has to has
to
at that point pay for it and i do
remember whoever asked the question
about i mean you want every customer you
can get i do remember when i was at
fairpoint this gentleman had called me
up and said
well you won't come down my road i built
this spec house and it's three miles
down this road and this was over in
keene or outside of king and i said well
you should have called me first because
bottom line we can take it so far but
we're not gonna pay
ten thousand dollars to get but you can
pay it and that was the only time i
actually i shouldn't say this in front
of sierra but i actually recommended
that he use a different carrier because
there was a carrier who had a guy over
in keene who had a fixed wireless which
was going to be cheaper for him and he
did it so there are things you can do
but um and it just depends on where you
are and who the company is whether
they're gonna you're gonna have to pay
after they get to the end of their their
polls
all right i would like to bring miss
davis up now and have her sit beside you
ms rosenberger so that uh she can give
us uh her insights
and then um we can
direct questions to both of you so
ms davis uh representing um
consolidated communications could you
give us your um take on this legislation
and then and then we'll open it up to
questions to you too okay wonderful and
i'll try to try to answer all the
questions but certainly there are a lot
of good ones so if i miss anything i'm
sure you'll follow up but good afternoon
chairman vos and vice chairman thomas
and distinguished members of this
committee
consolidated communications is
absolutely committed to the state of new
hampshire we're committed to broadband
deployment in new hampshire we're
upgrading with fiber over four hundred
thousand locations over the next five
years enabled completely by private
investment
we have taken money from the rural
digital opportunity fund which is the
fcc's fund that replaced the universal
service fund that existed before to
upgrade very rural areas of the state we
have public private partnerships with
over 15 municipalities in the state
where we are putting in fiber to the
premise service offering one gig
symmetrical we're absolutely committed
to the state
with respect to this bill it does date
back to the 1934 act um which was then
amended by the 1996 act and the purpose
of that amendment was to encourage
competition because ideally there's a
free market for everything right and
regulation steps in when the free market
isn't working and it was very successful
for the most part right i wish i wish
everyone had a landline if everyone had
a landline we wouldn't be here today um
and and to the question about pushing
people to cellular service we have not
pushed them there they have gone there
unfortunately and if you look at your
state's 911 metrics you know well over
75 percent of calls are coming 911 calls
are coming from wireless
devices and and then a substantial
portion and i don't know the number
sitting here from cable devices and then
only a small portion is left coming from
a true landline but offered by the
incumbent local exchange carrier and
that's that's the fundamental change
that has enabled this legislation that
is requiring this legislation is that
there is still a requirement on
incumbent local exchange carriers that
is not on its competitors it is required
to continue and maintain and offer
service in places where it may not make
sense to
and and as all your questions get to we
appreciate the importance of continuing
to offer service to those who are really
going to be left without it and so
that's why we've set the bar pretty high
to your point 97 and 95
is is a pretty high bar it's recognizing
that there will be somebody who is 10
miles down the road who just isn't
served and frankly a lot of times
doesn't want to be served they they
built way out in the middle of nowhere
to be off the grid and so it strikes the
right balance i'd point out that 95 and
97 percent of manchester is a
significant number but also because of
that density manchester has very good
service and you'll probably find it's
100 hundred percent as you get into
smaller municipalities those percentages
turn into a very small number and and
that's where that analysis came from
that's the analysis we did in maine at
the time we did it it resulted in 21
municipalities um that were eligible for
deregulation and if you read the 21
municipalities as theresa points out
you're talking portland's in west brooks
and very well served areas of the state
it would be similar here so the
cornishes and i don't know cornish in
particular but i'm guessing it's got a
significant portion that's lacking a
competitor
there is a possibility you know oh
i'm
completely honest person i'm an open
book there is a possibility that um
in the future some this other competitor
could leave but that's not how companies
typically act right they've taken the
time to invest in putting wire line
facilities or
to permit a wireless tower which is no
small feat um in an area to provide
service they made that investment
wanting to provide service there isn't
something that
precipitates a decision to just be done
in the future in fact if
consolidated were to just continue
providing which we have no plans to do
but if we ever were that's all the more
reason to stay because that's a bigger
piece of the pie right so that it's just
not how companies rational companies act
it's kind of like saying if we don't
mandate a grocery store all the grocery
stores would go away they wouldn't right
there's there's profit to be made there
so
um
i'm sorry i'm trying to think of some of
the other questions that were asked
do you want to just i'll just open it up
because you guys had such you get it you
had all the questions so i'll just let
you ask them yes we'll open it up to
questions but before we do that i'm
going to
35 fn and then recess that hearing for
10 to 15 minutes so we can continue this
hearing
all right so now let's go to the
questions representative partial has a
question
at your chair and think about no that's
fine
we chose
um
my question is um how do you determine
what is adequate cell coverage because i
know that in some of the places where i
pass through in the state
um you can be standing in one particular
spot in one second have service and next
second it drops it's that's kind of like
depend upon which way the wind is
blowing
um i don't know if that would qualify as
being part of that 97 percent or
yeah it's it's not always easy to
establish exactly where there is service
but there are significant coverage maps
that can be used please speak into the
mic i'm sorry it's very it's very
awkward
all right um it's it's not it's not
always easy to tell with respect to cell
coverage to a perfect extent there are
coverage maps that demonstrate the area
and that's sort of where the doe
oversight comes in we we allow the
opportunity to make rules to sort of
check into the information to the extent
possible it's not perfect nothing is
perfect but
in most instances when we've looked at
the data it's it's a hundred percent
coverage so there is plenty of wiggle
room for a little bit of space that
might not have coverage
thank you no follow-up
okay who's next representative samsic
thank you mr chairman and um
thank you um miss davis for and miss
rosenberg um
first of all i have a landline and i
also have
mobile phone lines
and i noticed from past experience that
landlines
have a lot of advantages
a doctor's office will fax you something
on a landline but they will not send it
to you by email or by mobile phone
for security reasons
the the other thing is that
the
the question i have also as concern is
when there is a a customer that
that
qualifies to be relieved of that
that landline that they have
there is no real assurance that that
person can get
affordable basic service from any other
provider
so maybe they have right now this basic
service which they're trying to keep as
low as possible cost wise
and if they are
you know they lose that landline
connection
um
they might end up like uh representative
kelly pittsburgh was mentioning first of
all having to buy expensive mobile phone
and secondly the service itself will be
more expensive so that means we're going
to be
shifting costs to people like that
for
what we think is a basic
uh need of any everybody whether
business or residence of having
phone and communications
is that is that
do i see that right i mean is that what
could happen to some extent um there are
there are programs um that are out there
that first of all you can get a free
cell phone and a certain bucket of
minutes that is a low income program
that is available for cellular phones
there are what they call them lifeline
cellular providers that provide that
service there's also a large shift in
and that's consistent with this there's
a shift at the fcc and a focus on
broadband and so they've shifted away
the traditional funding that underpinned
this whole premise when you talk about
rural electrification there was funding
for all of this right there was a
recognition this was a public good and
we would fund all this it's no longer
funded anymore
they've transitioned away from lifeline
they've stepped it down it's it used to
be 9.25 now it's down to 5.25 and it
goes away next year and the only
lifeline that'll be available is for
broadband all the focus is on broadband
and with a broadband connection you can
certainly do an over-the-top service and
so those tend to be affordable because
there's robust competition there so
there are programs out there that's
where all the shift has been and that's
what's precipitating this legislation is
that there has been a shift away from
everything that used to allow
consolidated to continue to make
maintain hundreds of thousands of miles
of wire
for you know what used to be hundreds
and thousands of customers has now
shrunk to you know not all that many
customers because the competition that
exists and the mandate to continue to
keep doing something that isn't frankly
subsidized and so your your concern is
one that is is accurate but the problem
is that
continuing to maintain these costs
while allowing competitors to take their
piece of the pie is an unsustainable
model at some point and so this is
trying to strike the right balance
between
um that unfunded mandate and and
ensuring that people really do have
access because there has to be a
demonstration that there's somebody else
there um so
it's it's not it's not a 100 guarantee
you know it's but it is trying to strike
that balance between um recognizing that
consolidated needs to compete and needs
to be not hamstrung from acting
consistent with its competitors and
ensuring people have service
we're running short on time so i'm going
to have to
limit it to one question for a member
um
i have a quick question i asked it
earlier uh approximately how much is the
puc assessment
our puc assessment i i'll get you an
exact number but it's about a couple
hundred thousand dollars for
consolidated and each telephone company
pays that and as i stated before it went
up this year and and they received a
call because we no longer even have a
telecom person there anymore um and
fairness to the doe it's done through a
formula and an assessment they you know
they're not coming after us in
particular or anything there but i think
it's time with no telecom staff left to
reset that formula probably
okay thank you representative callie
pitts one question one question
i had the question about the 911 system
and it and
and how much does it cost you
when you run wire
to now eliminate
the
cell phone service or the the landline
service
and replace that on
very similar wire
with broadband
um so
the the
standard industry estimate for running
fiber if that's what like like the
broadband we're building now today is
fiber-based broadband um to run fiber is
about five dollars a foot is what it
typically cost to run fiber was that the
i'm hoping we're going to have another
bite at the apple that wasn't the
question
i would like to know again the 911 is
really important to me they used to have
something i worked for the company
before you were born
and it was left in dial tone that
anybody could
plug in a phone service or not you could
call 9-1-1
uh similar services on broadband
do you would you do that if
you pulled out of an area would is is
there an ability for somebody to call
9-1-1
yes i mean to the extent there's
competition there's an ability for
i think but i think
the misconception maybe here is
if they are relieved of the carry of
last resort obligation
that doesn't mean they're leaving an
area it just means that obligation is
relieved
so the carry of last resort obligation
is that basic service
well
they
i don't know what you mean they don't
have to have they they
they can still have just
service that doesn't have call waiting
and
voicemail could i just uh suggest that
you ladies
yeah you ladies discuss this offline
representative bresni had a quick
question yes it's quick i was just
wondering about how many municipalities
would be affected if this bill passes
and and kind of a follow-up to that is
how much does that change if you
increase it the percentages by one or
two
i haven't done the analysis on
increasing the percentages
at current time based on
fcc data that carriers file with the fcc
i estimate it would be about 30 to 40
municipalities
and if i just may say the numbers that
are there are the the percentages are
pretty
pretty consistent with what has been
done around the country
these are not just pulled out for new
hampshire they're totally consistent
okay thank you
okay
in many areas yeah yeah well we'd like
to thank both you ladies for being here
giving us great testimony and providing
lots of wonderful answers to our
questions i would urge members if you
have additional questions that we
couldn't get to
to contact these ladies via email
to
find out
get the answers to your to your
additional questions
so with that i'm going to close the
public hearing well
before we do that blue sheet data on
this public hearing representative
pimentel
two names both opposed
okay two names opposed and on the online
one
one support 36 suppose all from new
hampshire
okay
thank you
all right with that we will close the
public hearing on
house bill
1328 fn
and we will now
reopen
the public hearing on house bill
1635 fn and i will call to the
testimony table representative kat mcgee
who is the prime sponsor to introduce
this bill representative mcgee it's all
yours
thank you chair votes and esteemed
colleagues of house science technology
and energy
i come to you today as the prime sponsor
of hb 1635
a bill with bipartisan support in favor
of updating new hampshire statute with
regard to the purchase of output from
limited electric energy producers also
known as leap
and qualifying storage
as the energy market expands to include
a variety of contributors the need for
updated statutory language that
accurately represents and defines that
market becomes our challenge
in the last two years multiple attempts
have been made to add simple language
that is represented in hv 1635 this
language defines who qualifies as a
limited electric energy producer by
clarifying that a leap is number one
a generator who's not engaged in net
metering
number two
not registered as a generating asset
with the iso new england or the
independent system operators
and uh
who managed the grid is this where i
left off and number three is not
participating in any wholesale
electricity market that would fall under
federal jurisdiction
since the generation from the limited
electric energy producer is not being
counted towards the centrally managed
generation and is supplying local
customers with energy that does not
travel long distances over state lines
or transmission lines
it presents a new challenge for
regulators to try and figure out how to
account for the value of this energy
market in the energy market
qualifying the leap category of the new
hampshire electricity market is the
purpose of the changes suggested by hb
1635 and its predecessor in 2021 hb 407
for which i was also the prime sponsor
the other new language included in this
bill adds qualifying storage to the list
of qualifying small generator types
in order to acknowledge the role of
storage in providing energy when the use
of stored energy is appropriate
both bills also quantify the generators
as having a discharge capacity between
one megawatt and up to five megawatts
although the bill
as written in 2021
secured 115 sign-ins in favor and only
two sign-ins opposed
there were remaining questions on the
committee
on this committee that made it a
candidate for further study
and a study committee was undertaken by
three members of this committee and two
members of the senate and chairman vos
served as the chair though the
definitions in hb 1635 are still
necessary
the study committee concluded there were
issues beyond these definitions for
which the legislature wanted answers
those questions mostly relate to
properly defining the small generator
market in such a way as to inject the
appropriate price signals and
competition to enable the free market to
work as intended
should we
count
should we count retail local generation
as load reduction since it diminished
our need to buy additional regional
electric supply
what's the process for calculating and
reimbursing the value of leap generation
who reaps the rate benefits
several members of this committee
uh
are signed onto a bipartisan senate bill
321 that actually takes a more fulsome
approach to addressing these questions
hb 1635
can be considered a subset of sb
321 and so we should understand that
passing hb 1635 in no way harms the more
comprehensive senate bill
the main reason for the brevity of this
bill is that it was filed prior to the
november 2021 leap study committee
report
uh i thank you for your time and i'll
thank you representative mcgee
for introducing hb
1635 representative plutt has a question
yes
from the title uh rather the analysis
do i understand that analysis is say
that a leap could be
created in nashua
it is unlikely
um but i don't have the answer for that
i think there are probably people here
who could answer you more specifically
that are more familiar with
whether that would
that would work
and whether any claim of transmission
savings would work when they're doing
that
okay uh representative harrington is
recognized for a question yeah thank you
mr chairman thank you for taking my
question uh speaking of that what was
just mentioned transmission savings they
go to uh page two of the bill and
there's a lot of cost about avoid
unreasonable cost shifting for
transmission rates and lower down the
page it says limited producers shall
receive credits for actual voyage
transmission charges and it goes on i
won't read the whole paragraph
and you would just mention that in some
ways these are like a load reduction
thing and of course we already have a
program in iso new england where you can
come in as a
a load reducer and you can get a uh
capacity supply obligation
and you get paid for reducing load uh
when demand is a certain time
and um
people there's quite a bit of this
there's
many many many megawatts of mod on that
but when you do this you don't get any
credit for transmission savings
so if you put on a
put in a whole mess of new motors or
go to new bulbing in a factory so you
can reduce the uh demand um
when it's called for to be reduced you
can get a capacity supply obligation not
only do you save the obviously money on
electricity but you save you get paid by
iso new england which means the rate
payers for that amount of money what you
don't get paid for is any transmission
savings that may or may not manifest
itself why do you want to carve this out
different with this in giving
transmission savings to this type of
thing when it's basically this basically
the same thing
thank you for your question
representative harrington
um
i think the point of this bill
and the other legislation that we've
been attempting is that this market this
region this local retail market which
does not participate
in the wholesale markets that have that
definition it does not have definition
in other words how we account
for
if there is load reduction
right that process is not defined in
statute at this point so the limited
electric energy producer in my
understanding is a separate category
that we have not yet defined
sufficiently so that we understand
whether if there are benefits coming
from someone in this role how we would
account for them so that the market's
operating properly so i think the iso
new england or the wholesale market
piece i in my testimony i specifically
said
leap
people participating in the limited
electric energy producer market
do not participate in that market so
we need rules for them that's the point
we have to think about that follow up
follow up okay just so i'm cleared so
what you're saying is it's a separate
set of rules
but
we don't even though the effect on the
overall grid is a reduction in the
amount of electricity needed because
you're being produced through this
leap process rather than through the
normal generation system
that is the same as if someone
reduces the demand for electricity and
takes a capacity supply obligation but
one case for the leap you want to get
them to be paid for transmission savings
and the other case
uh they don't it's just so i'm clear is
that which that's what you're proposing
yep
yeah i think the
way that i would understand it is this
is a new category of someone who's
contributing in terms of electricity so
you you mentioned a couple of examples
um like light bulbs you know that there
are other ways that we save electricity
or or reduce load but i don't think
that's at the same capacity so this is
sort of a retail piece that's in between
the wholesale piece and the individual
changing out light bulbs
that is unaccounted for the way we do
things today and so we want to try and
put some definition around if there is a
value let's get on it figure out what it
is and then make sure that it works
appropriately
okay additional questions for
representative mcgee
i have one following along
with the question from representative
harrington going back to page 2 line 20
the limited producer shall receive
credit for actual avoided transmission
charges what is your understanding of
hmm
i
i don't have an answer i'm not sure okay
i'm not sure how it will operate in the
system
um
i think the
language here is just to say that that
there
should be a way for them to even if it's
credited to them
when they're
it's credited to them on their bill and
this is a calculation for what that
avoided cost is but i'm not really sure
and i'm sure there is somebody behind me
that would be able to answer that
okay great i'll ask
okay someone else
additional questions for representative
mcgee
seeing none i thank you representative
for introducing this bill and now i'll
call on the honorable clifton below
who is here representing the community
power coalition of new hampshire to
testify on behalf of this bill nice to
see you again mr bilo
good afternoon take it away thank you mr
chairman um
i'm here on behalf of the community
power coalition of new hampshire which
is a
newly incorporated governmental
instrumentality uh foreign pursuant to
rsa 53a
uh
n53e
53ea provides for municipalities county
subdivisions to operate powers jointly
through through a vehicle if it's
approved by the attorney general in
terms of its legal form we went through
that process
there are 18 member communities 17
municipalities in one county county of
cheshire county the 17 municipal members
of the coalition uh comprise about 18 of
the state's population um
and
what part of what this coalition is
interested in doing is supporting the
development of community power
aggregation including enabling
market-based alternatives to
expanded net metering
that would put
competitive suppliers and municipal
aggregations sort of on a level playing
field with the utilities in terms of uh
values that they can be recognized in
terms of um
value produced um
and uh
in the intent of this legislation
which has been uh versions of it have
passed the senate over the past couple
of years um and and uh have been brought
to this committee is to try to create a
uh
a market structure where there aren't
cross subsidies in either direction um
and and try to do it in a way that is um
that they can that can actually work um
as a complement to the iso new england
um interstate wholesale market to enable
a sort of a local distribution level
market that sort of parallels that
i should note that the statute
that this reforms are say
a 362 a 2a
purchase of output by private sector has
been on the books in new hampshire since
1979 so so this idea is not a new policy
the law currently provides that a
producer a limited producer
under you know up to five megawatts uh
could sell its um energy to not more
than three purchasers other than the
franchise utility which could be any
entity within the state um and could
sell them more if the commission
approves it the current law also
provides that
such limited producers may receive
actually not be charged for the
transmission tariff or rate for such
sales if transmission facilities or
capacity under federal jurisdiction are
not used or needed for the transaction
that that
law legal structure is a bit archaic in
terms of all the requirements so these
um bills are trying to move and reform
that and as representative mcgee pointed
out um the chairman of this committee uh
chair chaired also the
commission to study limited electrical
producers um which as he discovered you
know this is not there are a lot of
complexities to this issue um and i i
did print the copy of that report and uh
the appendices which which are the
submissions written submissions that
were provided to the committee it's also
available online through the general
court website and you can access
hyperlinks there but i know sometimes
it's nice to just have the paper copies
i'll just go ahead and and hand those
out and and be re available for
questions i do think that you know this
bill might be appropriate to think of
this as a sort of a preview of what's to
come um perhaps from the senate bill
because i do think the senate bill is
more fully informed by the work of the
study commission and there's some
aspects of this bill while maybe an
improvement over what was being
considered last spring as part of senate
bill 91 you know kind of um
didn't really you know there's still
issues with the bill as introduced um
that could be thought about but um
this will provide you some background
perhaps to prepare for the senate bill
to come over where you might have more
thank you for providing those that hard
that go ahead mr representative
now let's let's hold the questions until
uh i'm done oh you're done
i just figure i don't need to get into
the details at this point because
um i think people want to read you know
want to read the report before you start
discussing this in depth
okay representative harrington has a
question
uh thank you mr chairman let me take my
question i'm just trying to figure out a
little bit more of this on page one
on line 20. it talks about a limited
producer of electricity may sell its
electrical energy one or more purchases
other than the franchise utility
and then if we go over to page two
to line 15
it says the department of energy should
adopt rules to provide reasonable
customer protection for all
retail sales of electricity from limited
producers which may include the
requirement for prior review and
approval of such contracts before they
go into effect
it sounds as if
on page one you're talking about a
voluntary
agreement between a limited producer and
someone who wants to buy their product
and then you turn around in the second
page and say but this may require
approval for the department of energy
why would they be involved at all
um
that's a good question it's partially a
carryover from the current statute that
that actually calls for the commission
to review
each individual contract and
and says it may disapprove any contract
which in its judgment
fails to protect both parties from
excessive liability or undue risk and
you know it says a couple more things
you know the impact on the utility or is
inconsistent with the public good so to
some extent that language was to replace
what's already in statute and sort of
just bring it more up to date i think we
heard i've heard in some testimony on
related bills a concern that
that's that residential or even small
business customers might not realize
what they're getting into so that maybe
there should be some review of this
i i know i think that's a ways off if
this does become enabled i think it's
some years off before small
customers would be entering into
contracts but i do know from our own
survey of businesses in the community
that there are several
large you know businesses that have
full-time energy managers who procure
power now who said they'd be very
interested if they could enter into a
long-term purchase power agreement with
like a three or four megawatt local
solar and battery storage facility uh
they would they would like to be able to
do that so that they can say they're
sourcing some of their power locally
they just don't have room on their land
to do what they to do it themselves so
this would be a vehicle for that i i
don't really think a responsible party
like that would would need to have their
contract reviewed but but it's there
because there was concern that that
might be appropriate for small customers
follow-up
it's from what i'm saying then in a real
competitive market it would be up to
this the buyer to look at the contract
and take care of themselves this is sort
of like a step back to
big brother regulation then right in in
in the same way that the
puc or now the doe you know has rules
and regulations concerning competitive
suppliers and what they have to disclose
as their terms particularly for
residential customers so that they
they're not kind of abused right thank
you
unless the same one i asked earlier
under this bill
i'll reverse the polarity somebody could
generate something in colebrook and sell
it in nashua is that correct and how
does that avoid transmission um the only
way you avoid transmission charges
is and and that's what the bill provides
for only if there's actual reduction of
actual transmission charges is by
reducing the load on the transmission
system at the hour of coincident peak
demand um
the highest hour of demand for each in
each month um the the
transmission cost whether it's for the
regional network service or what's
called local network service which is
which is still um crosses state lines
those costs are allocated to
um
in theory under the iso new england
tariff to to the um load serving
entities but in new hampshire instead of
doing that it's it's allocated to the
distribution utilities but it's based on
their share coincident peak essentially
either measured or estimated at the
interface of the transmission grid in
the distribution grid so if you're
producing power and colebrook and it
actually reduced the coincident peak on
wherever it interconnects to the
transmission grid then it would produce
a reduced transmission charge and that
would be where there's credit
out all other hours of the month
there's no charge
um either cost or savings with regard to
transmission
and as long as the off taker is within
the same state it's still a state
jurisdictional transaction um and kind
of going to the question of how does the
credit work now in liberty utilities for
instance they justified a
utility sponsored battery pilot program
um in their investment of it um
and being able to put it in rate based
based on the trends avoided transmission
cost and capacity cost primarily
and they simply said what they measure
through interval meters what the
batteries produce onto the grid at the
time of the hourly monthly peak they try
to manage them so that they dispatch
them at those hours of coincident peak
and if they measure a reduction in in
that uh
then they're giving credit for it in in
the formula by which they justify it it
is being added to rate base because it
produces a lower transmission charges
and a lower overall capacity take for
liberty customers
so this is just trying to say let the
competitive market be able to compete
with that kind of regulatory scheme
and
and this is also happening with
you know the utilities in other states
in new england as well using avoided
transmission and capacity cost as as
part of the financial justification
for these programs
follow up
yes thank you
if i were a utility
billing system manager
with something like that i'd be pulling
my hair out is how do you keep track of
the generation in one place and the
credits in another place and make sure
that the generation matches up with the
credits
and that's an added cost to the utility
that i don't see being picked up by
anybody in this bill well the utility
doesn't need to do that accounting the
bill uh calls for the load serving
entity to um take care of that
the the load serving entity would have
to be the same entity for both the off
takers and the supplier
unless they made arrangements with other
load-serving entities where they could
you know kind of commingle um
uh but um that that what what they do
now and what they're required to do by
law now i'll just take the net metering
example if if you've got a net metered
customer who's on competitive supply or
um
with a with a municipal aggregation
although none exists yet
then the law currently requires the
utility to take the negative exports to
the grid for each hour if if they're
measured and use those or even if
they're not if they're estimated and use
those to offset the power supply to
customers of the same load serving
entity so that the load serving entity
pays for the net cost
um
and that that so they're currently doing
that accounting with regard to net meter
facilities i might add eversource in
particular their western mass utility
which apparently uses the same billing
system as their new hampshire public
service of new hampshire they actually
have this functionality already for
transmission charges because some of
their large industrial customers are
charged
transmission charges directly not as
part of a distribution utility charge
and they actually do measure for those
large customers in their current metered
data system and their billing system
when those customers are
what their load is at the system
coincident peaks in which transmission
charges are allocated and then they pass
those isola england charges over to
their customers um
and
so so it's basically the same
functionality that already exists at
least in the eversource system in
okay thank you
so you've heard me ask this question
before i'll ask it again
line 20 on page two
the limited producer shall receive
credit for actual avoided transmission
charges
describe
how those credits
work
and the information you just revealed
about the eversource uh
system in massachusetts uh seems to
maybe offer a clue there um describe how
it could work
and
tell us whether
it would impose any charges whatsoever
on
non-limited
okay um well let's say take a
hypothetical there's there's a limited
producer of some sort
that produces one megawatt of power
at the monthly system peak
um that will in liberty the co-op in
unitil's case actually results in a
little more than one megawatt maybe
1.06
megawatts of reduced load at the meter
point where the transmission grid
interfaces with the distribution grid so
if at that point say there's typically a
20 megawatt load and you've got a
limited producer that puts a megawatt
onto the grid you'll actually measure 19
megawatts at that hour of a system
coincident peak and they'll be charged
based on 19 megawatts times whatever the
rate is uh for the month the whole month
rate is embedded in that single hour
um
so
in in the sort of simple math formula is
but for this particular limited producer
and what they put out at that hour of
system peak um the charge would have
been for 20 megawatts plus the line
losses so you've got the rate so you
just look at okay what's the delta it
put one megawatt on at you know times
that rate that's the credit they get
because that's what we would have paid
otherwise to get that power delivered
over the transmission grid at the
monthly system peak the the reverse way
to think about this and i think this is
one of the things that senate bill 321
tries to offer as an alternative way of
thinking of this which which is already
reflected in in the transmission tariffs
and isa new england
policy is that the transmission charges
could be directly allocated to the load
serving entity rather than to the
distribution utility and and so in that
and several state tariffs actually
provide for that national grids tariffs
actually spell that out as an option i'm
not sure it's actually been implemented
in new england it is the way it works in
some other
areas i think in pjm uh they they pass
transmission through to the load serving
entity so let's just say there's a
competitive electric supplier
limited producer
and normally they've got a 14 you know
they'd have a 14 megawatt load from all
their customers that are taking power
but they got one megawatt being put onto
the grid from one of their customer
generators or i should say limited
producers uh that sort of part of their
portfolio uh then they would um
be only charged for 13
13 megawatts um because that that was
their measured load the the the
utilities already
their hourly loads are
and that's supposed to be net of exports
to the grid by net meter generators um
but it will you know you'd treat these
in the same way
so so they're already making those
calculations for the load serving entity
and if you just allocated transmission
on the same basis then then that load
serving entity could decide whether they
give that where they charge everyone as
if they bought 14 megawatts of
transmission service at that coincident
peak or whether they charge um um and
give the the one megawatt credit to the
producer or if they don't give the
credit to the producer but they lower
everyone else's charge um up as you know
because they're only being charged for
13 megawatts even though their customers
consume 14 megawatts so it just depends
on how they chose to do it but again
that leaves it to sort of the market to
decide actually how to structure those
details
and now you know why i didn't answer
that
so would it be correct then to to think
of these credits as really just being
lower rates yes for transmission so
there there isn't really a credit in
this in the sense of
like a net metering credit it's just
that
the transmission rate charged would be a
lower rate
based on
the
uh
coincident peak
determination right of what the rate
should be right
exactly and and so why do we use the
word credit in the in the legislation
well
because um
that that's another way to do it i mean
that's what's happening in net metering
now if you're under if you're up to
100kw you get a credit when you export
to the grid equal to the full
transmission rate you know which whether
you actually help reduce transmission
charges or not um
uh so but but that's that's a credit
that's given now
um in in net metering and and that
that just might might be an easier way
to do it than the other way because the
other way would be new for new hampshire
so but but it might you know but it's
worth i think considering because i
think part of the whole concept of
restructuring was to have appropriate
price signals that that reflected sort
of underlying cost causation that
would give
both individual customers as well as
sort of groups of customers where
there's some some management support
an ability to adjust their consumption
to help minimize cost and and and this
just tries to do the same thing you know
representative harrington talked about
the development in iso new england of
sort of these demand response markets um
which as he may recall he was working on
that for the puc at the time the whole
demand response was being developed i
was a commissioner at at the time and
and part of you know advocating for that
to be part of the um interstate
wholesale market but in large part only
because we hadn't enabled it at the
state level you know we just don't have
the granularity of price signals at the
at the distribution level that that
businesses or generators could take
advantage of the fact that if they
produce or curtail load at particular
hours there's there's particular value
to that
in terms of capacity if you're helping
meet the peak demand then then the idea
was here's a way to get credit for it
but in doing so you sort of are forced
to into a
engineering or physics fiction which is
the notion that a small generator that's
offsetting load on the distribution grid
actually sells up into a central
clearinghouse you know out of state and
resells the power back over the
transmission grid so that's why they
don't get credit for transmission
because they're because they're part of
the um
regional market and and this bill says
you can do one or the other you could
participate in those programs in the
interstate wholesale market or here's a
way to do it locally on the distribution
system and sort of get the same kind of
price signals
excellent
additional questions for
seeing none thank you very much for
checking down here and i thank you for
study committee report hard copy for
everyone thank you appreciate that all
right we've got a couple more people who
would like to testify including our
good friend griffin roberge from the
good afternoon committee members uh for
the record uh griffin roberts from the
department of energy i have alongside me
today david wiesner from the department
as well
uh legal counsel for the department um
the department is neutral on this bill
but we just wanted to
express a few observations a few
concerns um obviously as you
already have and i do have coffees if
needed but you should have a copy of the
uh final report that was issued by the
senate bill 91 study commission or the
lepa study commission
um
as you'll identify on the report there
were significant amount of complexities
uncertainties and potential risks
associated with the proposal to expand
lipa retail sales
and provide avoided transmission charge
credits to participants in those
transactions um the report had warned of
unintended consequences and the
potential for cost shifting from one
class of electricity customer to another
um
you'll note in the report that it
concluded a wide range of recommended
next steps all of which largely aimed on
further study of the many complexity of
these complex issues that were
identified in the report whether by the
legislature the department of energy or
through a limited type of pilot program
that would likely be approved by the
public utilities commission
none of the study committee's
commission's recommendations involved in
implementation through rulemaking by doe
so in that regard this bill might be a
little bit premature
among the complex issues that would
benefit from further clarification are
the types and costs of necessary utility
metering and system upgrades needed to
facilitate these type of these types of
lipa transactions and the allocations of
those costs for recovery
so for example should only customers
participating in the covered
transactions pay these costs or should
they be covered by all the utility
customers or should the cost be split in
some way
the role of competitive electric power
suppliers and utility default energy uh
service providers is also unclear
those suppliers might need to provide
backup or supplementary service if and
when limited power producers many of
which are intermittent generation
resources uh may not be able to serve
all the retail customers electricity
requirements
um limited producers may be able to
provide electric capacity and energy to
retail customers at certain times and
under certain uh circumstances but it's
unlikely they'll be able to meet a
retail customer's full demand for such
products nor will they be able to
provide the full requirements um load
following service that retail customers
require obviously at all times
um the balance of a retail customer's
electric
supply requirements that can't be met by
a leaper generator again whether at
specific times or at all times will have
to be covered by a competitive electric
supplier or by the utility default
service supplier
the potential for additional costs
associated with that backup service will
either be have to be assessed to the
limited generator
or its retail customer or they'll have
to be recovered from other utility
customers
if these backup costs are assessed to
the leaper generator or a retail
customer then the cost of such
transactions will be increased and their
financial justifications will likely be
diminished on the other hand if those
costs are instead recovered from the
utility customers
you would run into the potential of cost
shifting from participating to
non-participating customers
with respect to the point you raised
chairman votes about regional
transmission charges it is likely that
some portion of those charges
is avoided by the electric output of
limited power producers that are
interconnected to the utility
distribution system and those avoid
costs would tend to benefit all utility
customers however the scope and scale of
these avoided transmission charges and
how much cost savings should be
allocated remain open questions
as i'm sure the committee is well aware
doe is currently looking at similar
issues
and the value of distributed energy
resources study that's being conducted
through a docket at the puc
that study is expected to be completed
by late spring of this year and that
will inform you know you guys as well as
all other stakeholders at this point
um
there's also a potential disconnect in
the bill
um i'm looking at paragraph five which i
believe is on page two i'm looking at
lines twenty to thirty
um
it would provide that the limited
producer shall receive credit for actual
avoided transmission charges um but
paragraph six thirty one two three page
uh sorry lines 31 to 34
um seem to contemplate that the retail
customer would also pay reduced
transmission card charges based on that
credit so these two provisions kind of
taken together kind of result in a
mismatch
unless the producer is required to pass
through the amount of the credit and its
pricing and billing for the retail
transactions i'm almost done last one
i want to address the proposed
bills consumer protection requirements
for the department rulemaking again on
page two
the bill apparently requires the
department um
to create rules to provide for the
filing or reporting on contracts for
interstate and direct sales by limited
producers
and also to provide quote reasonable
consumer protections for retail uh sales
of electricity from limited producers
which may
include a requirement for prior approval
and review and approval of such
contracts before they go into effect
while these protections seem well
intended
the committee should be aware that
limited electric energy producers are
not currently subject to regulation
by the department or the puc
they are not public utilities subject to
obviously extensive regulation as you
guys are aware nor are they competitive
suppliers required to be registered with
the department and to comply with price
disclosure and other customer
enrollment obligations set forth in the
ministry of rule so in effect this bill
would expand department regulator
regulatory jurisdiction to a set of
entities that are not currently
regulated
i'm hoping you guys could all follow me
through that and everything but uh if
you have any questions i did bring david
wiesner here with me today and he can
certainly answer them more robustly than
thank you
thank you uh mr robarge and mr wiesner
for being here this afternoon to answer
our questions on this legislation
and uh representative plett would like
to lead off i would just like to ask the
spelling of mr wiesner's name so i can
get the clerk's duties correctly thank
you well that's an easy one and
hopefully i can handle it w i e s
r i'm the legal director at the
department of energy but i also have a
lot of subject matter experience with
net metering with the liberty battery
pilot uh program that uh mr bilo
referenced earlier and i think i've
looked at this bill or versions of it
over the past few years
thank you representative harrington has
a question uh more of a request thank
you mr chairman it looked like you had
written testimony could you make that
available to us
i can certainly submit via email thank
you
okay additional questions mr
representative luikee
thank you mr chair and thank you um i'm
hearing mention of the coincident peak
and intermittent producers doesn't this
lead to somewhat of a crapshoot
basically if somebody happens to be
producing at the coincident peak then it
goes one way if not then uh things can
be completely different and if so would
how would this
might this actually increase rates to
ratepayers well i believe the intent of
the bill is that if a limited producer
is exporting power to the distribution
system at the time of the monthly
coincidence system peak
that there would be reduced transmission
charges assessed to the utilities
and that a portion of that would be
made available as a credit to the
generator
and and that is those types of avoided
costs have been recognized by the puc
and the doe
and as mr roberge noted we are currently
taking a close look at that in the
context of the value of distributed
energy resources study which is being
conducted in the pucs net metering
docket and it's also being tested real
world if you will in the uh literally
excuse me liberty battery pilot program
one of the chief
um sort of justifications for that
battery pilot program is the uh
potential to reduce
what are called regional network service
and local network service charges to
utilities
based on the ability to reduce load on
the distribution system at the time of
that monthly coincidence system peak
i'm not sure that answered your question
but
okay
additional questions for
the gentleman from the department of
energy
representative mcgee you can
ask a question it's a point of
clarification actually okay um
mr roberge when you testified you
mentioned uh on line 20 where it's
describing that the limited producer
shall receive credit for avoided
transmission charges
and then you said that you thought that
that was inconsistent with section 6
on line 31
and i think on line 31 it's basically
saying the purchasers that would enter
into that purchase power agreement would
have
the responsibility to pay and then it
lists a bunch of things and
basically it
transmission charges as they may be
adjusted so
i think it's just really outlining whose
responsibilities each of those things is
i don't think they're actually
inconsistent
but i just
thought i'd mention that because i i
looked at it when you said it and read
it a few times and i i don't think they
i think they're talking about two
different
um
two different participants in the system
and what they are responsible for
so if there were no charges then they
wouldn't be responsible for them but if
there are any then they're the ones who
are responsible at least that's how i
read it i think we identified a
potential mismatch because there are two
different parties being referenced so if
the credit is going to the generator
but there's a reduction in the charges
that would be paid by um by the customer
to its interconnected utility
then it's not clear that's a one-for-one
trade-off and if it's not then
somebody's either getting over-credited
or not paying enough now it might be
possible to solve that through rules
but
the the legislation as written leaves
that somewhat unclear and we just wanted
to flag that okay thank you
okay additional questions for the
okay uh i have a
another question uh seeing none from the
rep uh the honorable clifton bilo
mentioned senate bill 321 i don't know
has that bill been heard before the
senate as yet
uh to the best of my knowledge it has
not but it is obviously referred to the
senate energy and natural resources
committee
okay
so i guess it would not be jermaine to
ask questions about it if it hasn't been
heard so i'll just go read it and
get my questions answered that way all
right
further questions for the gentleman from
doe
none
represented
wiki thank you mr chairman this is more
or less a follow-up to my previous
question
is the coincident peak knowable other
than in hindsight
can you tell ahead of time that it's
going to occur or
does can you say oh it happened at such
and such time on such and such day
yeah you really don't know until it's
happened
so you can i mean for instance in the
liberty battery pilot program they are
targeting those peaks but it's
particularly hard in some of what we
call the shoulder months of the year
in uh you know in april or in october
you don't know exactly when the peak is
going to occur and you don't have
as good forecasting information about
when it's going to be a hot day a cold
day and that may drive electric demand
you can probably guess the range of
hours it's going to occur
on average but given you know the
participation specific day and hour is a
hard thing to know so you really don't
know until after the fact and it's
really a billing mechanism
for the uh for the iso and for some of
the transmission providers to
charge their trans their share of
transmission charges to
the distribution utilities which then
okay
well seeing none
i guess we'll move on and thank you both
for uh being available to answer our
questions we have one more person who
would like to testify on this build
and that is kelly buchanan from clean
energy new hampshire so ms buchanan
please uh have a seat and uh
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
kelly buchanan director of legislative
and regulatory affairs for clean energy
new hampshire
and i will be very brief today i
submitted written testimony to you via
email this afternoon around lunchtime
and
you know it's pretty short we see house
bill 1635 as something that we support
in terms of the goals but perhaps the
committee would consider i'm holding on
to this bill in some manner via interim
study or another means to more fully
consider senate bill 321 if it does
cross over
because
as the honorable mr bilo mentioned that
bill considers the study committee's
reports that you all have in your hands
today
clean energy new hampshire is certainly
supportive of this reform in general and
i won't repeat all the wonderful things
that mr bilo shared with you today i
find them all
agreeable and we're supportive of that
so i would be happy to take any
that was very brief you took me by
surprise in fact
does anyone have a question for ms
buchanan
sorry we didn't get to read your
testimony uh ahead of your
uh being here but um
in the future if you could submit it 24
hours in advance that would give us a
chance to take a quick peek at it i
would be glad too of course i apologize
no problem
okay any more questions for ms buchanan
yes uh representative partial thank you
that's the was that email sent to the
committee or was it sent via the uh
our
house website
i sent you an email via the email the
entire committee listed under your
your standing committee webpage i did
not use the newly
created testimony submission form if the
committee has a preference it would be
helpful to know if which one is
preferred
i believe your general address is house
okay good to know
i'm not sure but you may want to
consider resubmitting that i apologize
for speaking here but yes i i'm looking
at my email now and i don't see it oh
okay i will so you may want to double
check to make sure that that it got
through
i'll do that um
but we appreciate you
you sending it to us uh one way or the
other of course thank you you're welcome
any uh representative platt has a
question
mr chairman she asked if the committee
had any preference i i don't know about
the committee but i like getting an
email so i don't have to go chase
another source
okay
anybody else have a preference they want
to express
uh representative pementel
i agree
okay good
email it is so uh we'll look forward to
seeing that all right thank you miss
buchanan we appreciate you being here
now i have a question for representative
mcgee
uh representative mcgee the
um
lipa study committee that met this fall
came up with several recommendations and
one of the
matter of fact the first recommendation
was create a new study commission to
more closely examine how to calculate
avoided transmission charges to provide
a firm understanding of what's involved
the second recommendation was submit
legislation to require the department of
energy and or the puc to conduct a study
on the mechanics of computing and
monetizing avoided transmission charges
and intermittent load reduction
so my question for you is would you have
any objection to this to an amendment to
this bill
that implemented one or
the other or maybe even both of those
recommendations
uh no i have no objection
um
i think
to the second one it sounds like we
don't know what the mechanism is but
it's not that there isn't a mechanism
it sounds like from the testimony
um from the honorable clifton below that
that there is actually a method already
for that it's just not known to us but
in the in the first um yeah certainly
well based on the testimony of mr
weisner i think that
there may be some doubt about what the
mechanics of
computing and monetizing those
credits would be so
it might be worthwhile to to ask the puc
to undertake a a docket to study that
representative plett you have a comment
yes i just wondered because neither of
those steps have been done
could this study go this bill go to
interim study so to weight the results
of those two studies
well what i was thinking about was
modifying this bill to ask to set up
that study committee or to request that
puc study to take place
so rather than ising this bill
i'm suggesting that we amend it
to
change
its charge if you would
i made my comment
okay thank you
uh representative harrington uh yeah i
guess a couple quick comments chris if
anyone came up with that coincident peek
when it comes out let me know and we'll
all get rich together because uh you can
make a lot of money if you knew that uh
second if we are going to look into this
transmission cost savings of the
coincidence piece i strongly recommend
we get the iso involved or someone from
there because first of all if you don't
speak isonian there's no way you're
going to be able to figure it out and uh
i i think if whatever that committee
goes forward we're going to need input
from them because they're the real
experts on it and be quite honest
there's only a few people outside of
that that really understand it and i
don't think anyone in this room fully
that is probably a correct statement
that lasts
with the possible exception of the
honorable clifton below all right so any
more comments uh representative partial
thank you chair votes my question is for
you if we do uh uh amend this with a
study commission of some nature or
another
um
would that preclude what we're gonna be
looking at when we get the senate bill
fee 21 come on over which i believe is
being heard on thursday but i'm not sure
no it would not preclude that
it would just transform this bill from
the bill that exists today to
either a study committee or a puc docket
request or both i'm fine with that
second okay and could i ask could we
discuss the recommendations in here just
to make sure that if we're going to do a
study committee that we
we undertake whatever questions we
actually need answered so can we
it's just very quick that you put two
bullets out there for me and i haven't
had a chance to absorb
uh
what we might want to uncover if we
well we're not going to do this today
anyway so you'll have time to
absorb that information
and we could potentially form a
subcommittee to
work on an amendment for this bill
we don't have to decide that right this
minute but we'll need to decide it
reasonably soon okay i just wanted to
know if you were open to that i am
that concept
okay anything uh further if not i would
ask representative pimentel to read the
in-house blue sheet and representative
representative pementel
uh
three names on the sheet
all in favor
thank you
72 support for oppose
all from new hampshire
okay thank you
with that we're going to close the
public hearing on hb 1635. i thank you
all for
being here today another productive day
before we leave representative sausage
you have a comment
yes thank you mr chairman mr chairman
could you just uh refresh our our
memories about the the plan for monday
yes so on monday
february 7th
which is a a week from yesterday we will
be
meeting here
at 12 30 there will be a subcommittee
work session on house bill 1644 chaired
by representative thomas
then at one o'clock we will continue the
public hearing on h.b 1644
as you'll recall we recessed it
a couple of weeks ago
that
continued public hearing will last only
for one hour
and then at two o'clock
meet an executive session to pass
judgment on our five early
bills which are hp's
14 19
hb 1506 hb 1601
and hb 1621
and hb 1644.
those five bills have to be
uh reported out by thursday february
10th so we're going to do it monday
february 7th
starting at 2 o'clock
now any member of this committee who
knows they can't be there
on monday
february 7th at 2 o'clock you need to
communicate with myself or
representative samsich to arrange to get
the required numbers to
any other questions representative
harrington uh yeah just uh chairman i
wanted to look at uh possibly scheduling
a subcommittee hearing for hb 1258
which is the um
that's the whole
puc doe bill and i expect to receive
something from uh chris elms probably as
early as this afternoon or maybe
tomorrow he's been meeting with the doe
i've also asked
ms gamash to coordinate with the
utilities on that so i hope to have that
stuff this week are we going on vacation
next week but i'd like to schedule some
kind of a subcommittee meeting i know
this rooms are tight so sometime the
week of the 14th
but i also want to know what the
availability is of the people on the
subcommittee no sense in scheduling it
if they're not going to be around so
does anybody that's on the subcommittee
have
a date they couldn't meet the week of
the 14th we can give michael some
possibilities to deal with that
everybody okay with that okay so so the
the house will meet in session probably
on thursday february 17th that's about
definite that's just about definite at
this point uh
the only thing i don't know is the
location right exactly where it'll be
but um
so i suggest monday february 14th
when you confirm the room i don't know
how you go about getting a room or
anything so you could uh we'll talk to
carrie morris and she will arrange that
for us and we'll plan on monday then and
i'll try to get that stuff out to the
subcommittee meeting members uh today or
tomorrow
does that sit well with all the other
members of the subcommittee i've
forgotten who you are but you know who
you are
and fred
fred's the last one over there okay
everybody's fine i'll say okay so
subcommittee for fine with me
okay the subcommittee for hb 12 58 on
monday 10 o'clock we'll try february
14th 10 o'clock is that okay with
everybody
okay
thank you i'll arrange that with carrie
morris
anything else anybody have anything they
need to uh to bring to our attention
i was just wondering if our hearings
could no longer be 9 a.m and then all
afternoon
because we just have to wait around all
day
well we're only we only have one more
day of public hearings and that's
tuesday
february 8th and there are no
um two-hour hearings they're all one
hour hearings they do start at nine
o'clock
but there's three before noon and then
three afternoon
so
and then we'll be done believe it or not
we'll be done with public hearings of
course we still have a lot of work to do
with subcommittees and executive
sessions but we'll have all the public
hearings done by
february 8th so that'll be uh
that'll be good work and i appreciate
everybody's hard work to to get us to
that point
these public hearings have been very
useful and very informative and i think
we're going to have a good time when we
finally get to exec session so
anything further if not
let's call this session
complete for the day and i thank you all
you